♪♪♪
(camera shutter clicking)
>> I HAVE BEEN A MODEL
OVER HALF MY LIFE,
AND IT'S BEEN
ONE INCREDIBLE JOURNEY.
IT WAS AND HAS ALWAYS BEEN
MY DREAM
TO PASS THE TORCH
OF BECOMING A TOP MODEL
TO GIRLS ALL ACROSS AMERICA.
NOW "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
IS SEEN IN OVER 110 COUNTRIES.
WE COVER THE GLOBE
FROM AUSTRALIA TO THAILAND,
CHINA, RUSSIA,
FRANCE AND GERMANY,
WHERE MY FRIEND
AND FELLOW SUPERMODEL
HEIDI KLUM
WAS HANDPICKED TO HOST.
>> (speaks in German)
>> BACK HOME,
THE COMPETITION IS GROWING
AND BECOMING CRAZIER
AND CRAZIER.
>> I WANNA BE A MODEL
WITH EVERY FIBER OF MY BEING.
>> ♪ YO, TYRA ♪
♪ I KNOW YOU LOOKIN' ♪
♪ FOR THE TOP OF THE TOP ♪
♪ IT'S ABOUT WHERE YOUR WHOLE ♪
♪ SEARCH NEEDS TO STOP ♪
>> I'M GOING SO BROKE
TRAVELING OUT
TO THESE CASTING CALLS,
THAT IF I DON'T MAKE IT,
I'M GONNA HAVE TO START
SELLING MY BODY ON THE STREET.
>> BUT OUT OF THOUSANDS
OF HOPEFULS,
JUST 33 GIRLS HAVE BEEN
SELECTED AS SEMIFINALISTS
AND FLOWN TO LOS ANGELES,
WHERE THE COMPETITION
IS JUST GETTING STARTED.
>> HI.
>> ERIN.
>> WHERE YOU FROM?
>> HI. I'M MELISSA.
I'M GONNA IMPRESS THE JUDGES
'CAUSE THEY'RE GONNA SEE
MY DRIVE AND MY HUNGER.
THEY'RE GONNA SEE THAT I'M HERE
TO BE NUMBER ONE.
>> I'M NATASHA.
I'M 21 YEARS OLD.
I'M FROM DALLAS, TEXAS,
BUT I WAS ORIGINALLY BORN
IN, UH, RUSSIA.
>> MY NAME IS JASLENE.
I WAS HERE LAST SEASON,
AND UNFORTUNATELY
I DIDN'T MAKE IT.
I'M SO HAPPY AND EXCITED
TO BE BACK.
>> THESE GIRLS THINK THEY KNOW
WHAT'S IN STORE FOR THEM,
BUT THEY HAVE NO IDEA.
>> THIS IS SO COOL.
WHERE ARE WE GOING?
UUH, WE GET TO GO TO THE BEACH.
I DIDN'T PACK NO BATHING SUIT.
>> HEY, LOOK AT THESE GUYS.
THEY'RE ARMY MEN.
>> MILITARY MUSEUM?
♪♪♪
>> IF I CAN DO IT,
I KNOW YOU CAN DO IT.
>> HEY.
>> I'M LIKE, WHERE ARE WE?
AND ALL I SEE IS "MARINE."
OH, DEAR GOD.
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN TO US NOW?
>> WHOO!
(cheering)
(patriotic music playing)
>> (cheering)
>> ALL OF A SUDDEN--OH, MY GOD!
I SEE JAYS COMING,
AND I'M SCREAMING.
I CAN'T BELIEVE
I'M SEEING THEM ALIVE.
(cheers and applause)
>> MISS J.--SHE WAS WEARING
HER SHORT SHORTS.
HER BUTT WAS IN SHAPE
BETTER THAN MINE.
IT WAS ALL TIGHT AND SCRUNCHED.
I SAID, "OOH."
>> MISS J. AND MYSELF
WELCOME YOU
TO TOP MODEL BOOT CAMP.
YOU GIRLS ARE NOT READY YET
TO MEET TYRA.
SO MISS J. AND MYSELF ARE HERE
TO GET YOU INTO SHAPE
BEFORE YOU CAN EVEN MEET HER.
>> (sternly) WE'RE SICK
OF YOUR BUSTED WALKS,
YOUR WHINING,
YOUR BITCHING, YOUR MOANING
AND YOUR COMPLAINING.
YOU'RE A BUNCH OF MODEL MAGGOTS.
>> WAIT A SECOND.
LIKE, BOOT CAMP?
MODEL BOOT CAMP?
AND THEY'RE CALLING US
MODEL MAGGOTS.
>> TODAY WE'RE REALLY
GONNA GIVE YOU GIRLS
THE AMMUNITION TO CUT IT
IN THIS COMPETITION.
>> MY DAD USED TO BE
A BOOT CAMP INSTRUCTOR,
AND I'M JUST SITTING THERE LIKE,
"MY GOODNESS. I'M GONNA BE DOING
PUSH-UPS. I'M GONNA BE DOING
OBSTACLE COURSES."
>> DO YOU KNOW
WHO CAROLINA HERRERA IS?
>> NO, SIR, I DO NOT.
>> YOU ACTUALLY
WANNA BE A MODEL?
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHAT YOU'RE
ABOUT TO GET YOURSELF INTO.
KEEP IT MOVING.
>> WE'VE GOT RED.
YOU CAN'T NAME AT LEAST
FIVE AMERICAN DESIGNERS,
YOU DON'T DESERVE
TO BE WALKING ANY RUNWAY.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO GO UNDER THAT CAMEL COVER
RIGHT NOW AND GET DRESSED
INTO YOUR UNIFORMS.
IS THAT CLEAR?
>> SIR, YES, SIR!
>> (blows whistle)
>> ALL RIGHT, GO.
♪♪♪
>> ALL RIGHT, GIRLS.
YOU GOT 30 SECONDS.
GET IT TOGETHER.
>> 30 SECONDS. LET'S GO!
>> 30 SECONDS!
>> "I'VE GOT THIS IN THE BAG"
WAS MY--MY FIRST IMPRESSION
OF THE OTHER GIRLS.
I JUST DON'T FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE THE AMOUNT
OF CHARACTER AND DETERMINATION
THAT I HAVE.
>> GIRLS,
I NEED YOU HERE RIGHT NOW.
>> COME ON!
HUSTLE, HUSTLE, HUSTLE!
>> LET'S GO. MOVE IT. FALL IN.
ATTENTION!
>> WE ARE GONNA START OFF
WITH A POSING COMPETITION
AND TEST YOUR KNOWLEDGE.
>> AND OUR FIRST POSE IS
"FASHION MAG."
>> WORK IT. COME ON.
YOU'RE TRYING TO WIN
A COMPETITION HERE.
GIVE ME SOME ANGER.
GIVE ME SOME GRR.
>> GRR!
>> WELL, THERE YOU GO.
DON'T LAUGH.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS IS,
MISS J.
YOU CALL THAT A POSE?
YOU GET DOWN AND GIVE ME
TEN PUSH-UPS, PLEASE.
THAT'S A MESS.
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I'M DOING.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE--
SO THEY CAN SHOW ME,
AND I'LL TRY AND FOLLOW ALONG.
>> ONE! TWO!
>> BECAUSE IT'S JUST MODELING.
WE'RE NOT CURING CANCER HERE.
>> LET ME SEE
IF YOU GUYS CAN GIVE ME
A CONCAVE BACK,
RICHARD AVEDON COUTURE POSE.
WHO HERE KNOWS
WHO RICHARD AVEDON IS?
(crickets chirping)
>> RICHARD AVEDON
IS ONE OF THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON PORTRAIT PHOTOGRAPHY.
>> WELL, I THINK
WE'VE GOT ONE GIRL HERE
WHO COULD ACTUALLY MAKE IT
OUT OF TOP MODEL BOOT CAMP.
SARAH, STEP FORWARD.
DO YOU THINK YOU'RE GOOD ENOUGH
TO WEAR A BADGE OF HONOR
FOR "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
BOOT CAMP?
>> SIR, YES, SIR!
>> SARAH WON.
SHE ONLY WON BECAUSE
SHE KNEW THE NAME OF THE GUY,
AND SHE ONLY KNEW BECAUSE SHE'S
A PROFESSIONAL PHOTOGRAPHER.
SO THAT WAS BULL.
(whistle blows)
>> ATTENTION!
>> WE ARE GONNA HAVE TO TAKE
YOUR HEIGHTS AND MEASURES.
>> THE ONLY THING
I WAS AFRAID OF THAT,
WHEN I TOOK MY SHOES OFF,
THERE WOULD BE A CORN
OR A BUNION
THE SIZE OF MY FOOT LIKE THIS.
(whistle blows)
>> I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME
YOUR BEST MODEL POSE.
>> WAIST--25 1/2. 33 BUST.
YOU'RE 5'10".
WITH A PADDED BRA, SHE'S 33.
WITHOUT THE PADDED BRA,
SHE'S 32.
>> WHITNEY...
>> BUST--40.
WHY ARE YOU SNICKERING?
>> BIGGEST BOOBS IN THE WHOLE
LINE.
>> MAYBE IF YOU
RELAXED YOUR CHEST,
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE
THE BIGGEST BOOBS.
>> THERE'S NO DOUBT IN MY MIND
THAT A PLUS-SIZE MODEL
CAN WALK THE SAME RUNWAY
AS NAOMI CAMPBELL.
>> DIANA.
>> I DON'T FEEL THREATENED
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT, YOU KNOW,
BY THE OTHER PLUS-SIZE MODEL.
I THINK IT'S GREAT.
>> 39.
WAIST--31.
HIPS--45.
>> YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE TWO OF US.
♪♪♪
>> I THINK I HAVE POTENTIAL,
AND I'M UNIQUE
BECAUSE I HAVE A DIFFERENT LOOK.
I'M PRETTY,
SO I THINK THAT I'LL MAKE IT.
(playing "Reveille")
>> YOU GIRLS LOOK SORRY.
>> WE WERE MARCHING AND MARCHING
AND MARCHING, AND OUR HEELS ARE,
LIKE, THIS HIGH.
>> I AM DEFINITELY NOT READY
FOR THE ARMY.
I MEAN, I CAN SMILE,
AND I CAN POSE, BUT PUSH-UPS
AND ALL THAT KIND OF CRAP?
IT'S DEFINITELY NOT FOR ME.
>> LET'S GET INTO
AN "AT EASE" POSITION.
>> (chanting indistinctly)
WHOO! WHOO! WHOO!
YEAH! HUH! HUH!
>> AAH!
>> WHOO! WHOO!
>> WE HEAR THIS NOISE,
AND HERE COMES TYRA,
ROLLING DOWN, STEPPING.
>> AAH!
>> LIKE, THAT'S SOMETHING
LIKE WE DO BACK HOME--STEP.
♪♪♪
>> (grunting)
>> GET IT, TYRA!
MY MOM IS GREEK,
AND MY GRANDFATHER WAS A SIGMA,
SO AS SHE WAS STEPPING,
I WAS LIKE, "GET IT, GIRL."
>> WHOO!
>> AAH!
>> (cheering)
>> WHEN I SAW TYRA,
MY HEART STARTED RACING.
I GOT PUMPED.
I WANTED TO DANCE AND STOMP
WITH HER.
>> ATTENTION!
MY MR. AND MRS. CAPTAINS
HAVE BEEN OVER THERE,
HANDLING BUSINESS FOR ME.
I SEE SOME POTENTIAL,
AND I SEE SOME GIRLS
THAT JUST MAY BE GOING HOME.
SO THIS WEEK
IT IS UP TO YOU
TO PROVE TO ME
THAT YOU HAVE WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE WHAT?
>> AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL!
>> WHAT?!
>> CAN YOU HANDLE THE TRUTH?
>> MA'AM, YES, MA'AM!
>> I LOVE THE SMELL
OF HAIR AND MAKEUP
IN THE MORNING.
IT SMELLS LIKE...
(inhales deeply) VICTORY.
OKAY.
THE NEXT TIME
I WILL BE SEEING YOU
WILL BE IN THE CASTING ROOM,
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU
THAT THIS IS CYCLE EIGHT
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
AND I WANT YOU
TO BE ALL YOU CAN BE,
NOT BITCH ALL YOU CAN BITCH.
I WANNA SEE MY WOMEN
BE TOP GUNS,
NOT TOP SON OF A GUNS.
I WANT YOU TO CONVINCE ME
THAT YOU NEED TO BE HERE,
BECAUSE THERE IS ONLY ROOM
FOR THE TOP GUNS.
GIVE ME THIS POSE RIGHT NOW
AND STRIKE IT FIERCE.
STRIKE IT FIERCE.
A.N.T.M. UP!
>> A.N.T.M. UP!
>> HERE PHI BETA SIGMA!
>> PHI BETA SIGMA!
>> A.N.T.M. UP!
>> KEEP GOING! PHI BETA SIGMA!
>> EVEN THOUGH SHE CAME OUT
AND SHE WAS DOING HER DANCE,
I COULD STILL SEE IN HER
THAT SHE HAS A LOT OF HEART
FOR US GIRLS,
AND IT BROUGHT TEARS TO MY EYES.
AS STRANGE AS IT SOUNDS,
I-I STARTED CRYING.
>> A.N.T.M. UP!
>> PHI BETA SIGMA!
♪♪♪
>> AAH!
>> OH, MY GOD.
TO BE OUT OF BOOT CAMP
IS AMAZING.
I'M SO EXCITED,
AND I JUST CAN'T WAIT
TO MEET TYRA.
>> (moans)
>> AAH!
OH, MY GOD!
>> WHY ARE YOU
SCREAMING SO LOUD?
>> 'CAUSE YOU'RE SO PRETTY!
OH, MY GOD.
>> WHAT ABOUT ME?
>> YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL,
BUT THIS IS--
>> THAT'S A LOT OF HAIR
YOU GOT WORKING.
IS THAT ALL YOU IN THERE?
>> NO.
>> (laughs)
>> IT'S A PIECE.
>> SHE SAID, "NO."
>> IT'S A PIECE,
AND, YEAH, TYRA, I DO HAIR.
OH, MY GOD. YOU'RE SO PRETTY.
>> OKAY, WHAT WOULD YOU DO TO ME
IF I WAS IN YOUR KITCHEN,
AND I WAS LIKE...
>> OH, MY--
>> "GIRL, KATHLEEN, HOOK ME UP.
I NEED TO GET MY HAIR DID,
GIRL."
>> WELL, MISS TYRA, I THINK
I WOULD CHANGE YOUR WHOLE LOOK,
TYRA. I WANNA SEE YOU
PUNK ROCKER, LIKE...
>> HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND
TO GETTING A MAKEOVER
AND ANOTHER HAIRDRESSER
UP IN YOUR HAIR?
>> GUESS WHAT?
I DON'T REALLY CARE.
I WILL DO ANY--
EVERYBODY ALWAYS ASKS--
TYRA, YOU'RE SO PRETTY.
>> SO ARE YOU.
>> (laughs)
>> STRUTTING ON THE STREETS
OF BROOKLYN--
THAT'S, LIKE,
MY ONLY MODELING EXPERIENCE.
LIKE, I HAVE
NO MODELING EXPERIENCE
WHATSOEVER. NOTHING.
YOU KNOW, MODELING IS
WHAT I REALLY, LIKE--
THIS IS WHAT IT IS.
THIS IS WHAT I WANNA DO.
THIS IS WHERE I WANNA BE.
>> (high-pitched voice)
YOU'RE SO BEAUTIFUL!
>> HELLO. (laughs)
>> TYRA,
SARAH WON THE POSING CHALLENGE
AT BOOT CAMP.
>> I HEARD.
>> AND WHERE'S YOUR MEDAL
THAT WE GAVE YOU?
>> IT'S STILL ON MY T-SHIRT.
I WASN'T SURE
IF I WAS ALLOWED TO WEAR IT.
I ALWAYS TELL PEOPLE, I'M LIKE,
YEAH, I'M, LIKE, 20 GOING ON 26.
NONE OF THESE GIRLS
CAN REALLY HOLD A CANDLE
TO WHAT I HAVE.
I WANNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I LOVE THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
I'M--I'M A FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
I LOVE EVERYTHING
ABOUT THE INDUSTRY--
HOW BLUNT PEOPLE ARE.
I'M FIERCE.
WHEN I WANT SOMETHING,
I GO AND GET IT.
THAT'S--
THAT'S MY ENTIRE PERSONALITY.
I HOPE THAT
TYRA REALLY UNDERSTANDS
THAT I HAVE WHAT IT TAKES.
>> I THINK SHE'S EXTREMELY CUTE.
I THINKS SHE'S ADORABLE.
I SEE A LOT OF
GREAT MODEL MOLDING THERE.
>> WHAT IS THIS...
>> WHOA!
>> OUTFIT?
>> I WISH THAT I HAD
MY SERGEANT SUNGLASSES ON,
'CAUSE THIS IS AN OUTFIT.
>> "LITTLE HOUSE ON THE PRAIRIE"
MEETS SUPERMAN
MEETS WONDER WOMAN.
>> I MEAN, I LOVE TO WALK.
I LOVE TO POSE.
I MEAN, I DO THIS
IN FRONT OF MY MOM ALL THE TIME.
IT'S SO FUNNY.
MY MOM SITS THERE
AND SHE PRETENDS
LIKE SHE'S TYRA.
...OOH, MY TIGHTS?
>> AND EARRINGS OFF...
AND THE BRACELET...
AND LET YOUR HAIR DOWN.
>> NOW YOU KNOW
I GOT A THIN WEAVE.
>> I WAS GONNA SAY--
THAT'S GONNA FALL ON THE FLOOR.
>> WHY IS YOUR WEAVE SO THIN?
>> I WENT TO GET A WIG
SEWN ONTO MY HEAD BECAUSE...
>> (laughs)
>> I'M GHETTO. I'M GHETTO.
I ADMIT IT.
>> THERE'S A WIG SEWN ON?
>> THE WIG IS SEWN ON LIKE SO...
IT'S SEWN ALL AROUND.
>> WHY SEW IT?
>> BECAUSE I WANTED TO BE ABLE
TO DO MY--MY--LIKE YOU DO.
I WANNA DO...
I WANNA BE FIERCE!
I MEAN, I'VE BEEN
MADE FUN OF ALL MY LIFE.
I WAS ALWAYS TALLER
THAN THE REST OF THE GUYS.
THEY THREW BASKETBALLS
AT MY HEAD
AND DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE THAT,
'CAUSE I WAS ALWAYS, LIKE,
THE GOOFY LITTLE NERD
IN THE CORNER.
>> MY NAME IS HEATHER.
I'M 18 YEARS OLD,
AND I'M FROM DEER PARK, TEXAS.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO, HEATHER,
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT AUTHORITY?
>> OKAY, WELL, MY DAD
WAS A BOOT CAMP INSTRUCTOR.
>> I CANNOT BELIEVE
YOU ACTUALLY WANNA BE A MODEL.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHAT YOU'RE
ABOUT TO GET YOURSELF INTO.
>> I CAN DEAL
WITH THE CRITICISM.
I CAN DEAL WITH YOU
UP IN MY FACE, YELLING AT ME,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT MY DAD DID.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO YOUR DAD
WAS A BOOT CAMP INSTRUCTOR.
SHOW THEM
HOW IT REALLY NEEDS TO BE DONE.
>> WHO DO YOU THINK YOU ARE?
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING AT?
WHAT'S THAT SMIRK FOR?
YOU BETTER STOP SMIRKING
RIGHT NOW!
GET DOWN AND DO PUSH-UPS
>> LOOK, I'LL DO SOME PUSH-UPS
FOR YOU, BABY.
YOU CAN GO YELL AT HIM.
>> WHY AREN'T YOU LOOKING AT ME?
LOOK AT ME NOW!
"MA'AM, YES, MA'AM," NOW!
>> YES, MA'AM.
>> GET DOWN AND DO PUSH-UPS.
CAN YOU NOT FOLLOW DIRECTIONS?
>> I DON'T DO PUSH-UPS, BABY.
I'LL DO A POSE.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET
NO PUSH-UPS.
>> (laughs)
>> I CAN TAKE THE CRITICISM,
AND I CAN APPLY IT
IN A POSITIVE WAY,
AND I KNOW HOW TO REACT.
AND I KNOW THAT
WHATEVER I'M BEING TOLD,
IT'S FOR MY OWN GOOD,
AND I JUST NEED TO SUCK IT UP
AND ACCEPT IT.
>> DO YOU THINK
SHE HAS WHAT IT TAKES TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?!
>> I'VE HAD ENOUGH YELLING
FOR TODAY.
>> BE QUIET! BE QUIET! (laughs)
>> (laughs)
>> HI!
>> SO, UM,
TELL ME ABOUT YOUR INSECURITIES.
>> MY INSECURITIES...
MY BIGGEST INSECURITY
IS MY VOLUME CONTROL,
BECAUSE I'M LOUD.
>> LIKE, HOW LOUD CAN YOU GET?
>> I GET VERY LOUD.
I TALK PROBABLY
ALMOST AT THIS LEVEL, LIKE,
WHEN I'M SITTING AT HOME.
>> HAVE YOU EVER
HAD YOUR HEARING TESTED?
YOU THINK THAT MIGHT BE--
HAVE SOMETHING TO DO WITH IT?
>> PARDON?
WHAT?
>> (laughs)
>> I'M A BARTENDER,
AND EVERYBODY--
I MEAN, I HAVE PEOPLE THAT,
WHEN MY SHIFTS CHANGE,
THEY CHANGE THE NIGHT
THEY COME INTO THE BAR,
'CAUSE THEY COME IN
TO HANG OUT WITH ME.
MY JOB IS TO BE EVERYONE'S
BEST FRIEND,AND EVEN WHEN
I DON'T LIKE SOMEBODY,
I KNOW HOW TO PLAY THE PART.
>> SHE LOOKS FOREIGN, LIKE SHE
SHOULD HAVE A FOREIGN ACCENT.
AND I THINK SHE EXPRESSES
HERSELF REALLY WELL.
SHE'S VERY SELF-AWARE,
AND I LIKE THAT.
>> (voice shaking) I'M NATASHA.
I'M 21 YEARS OLD.
I'M FROM RICHARDSON, DALLAS,
AND I WAS BORN IN RUSSIA.
(speaks in Russian)
>> (speaks in Russian)
>> WHAT IS... (speaks Russian)?
>> IT'S "HI." (laughs)
>> (in Russian) SMILE.
>> (laughs)
>> I FEEL MYSELF AMERICAN,
BECAUSE WE ALL FROM
DIFFERENT PLACES ORIGINALLY.
BUT WE ARE AMERICANS,
BECAUSE WE WANNA BE HERE.
WE WANNA LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> SO YOU GOT MARRIED--WHAT--
AT WHAT AGE DID YOU GET MARRIED?
>> I GOT MARRIED AT 18.
>> 18 YEARS OLD.
>> YEAH, I WAS, LIKE,
REALLY BABY.
>> AND HOW OLD WAS YOUR HUSBAND?
>> UH, HE WAS, UH, 40.
>> 40 YEARS OLD?
>> 18 AND 40.
WHERE DID YOU MEET YOUR HUSBAND?
A BUSINESS TRIP? MAIL ORDER?
>> THIS IS THE MAN
WHO CHANGED MY LIFE COMPLETELY.
THERE ARE NO OPPORTUNITIES
IN RUSSIA,
AND I HAD TO STRUGGLE
UNTIL I MET MY HUSBAND,
AND HE BROUGHT ME OVER.
(voice breaking) I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THAT I'M--I'M IN AMERICA
AND I WANT TO REPRESENT AMERICA
BECAUSE THIS IS THE COUNTRY
THAT CHANGED MY LIFE.
>> GO--GO PUT ON YOUR SWIMSUIT.
OKAY.
>> I WAS JUST CURIOUS TO KNOW
HOW--HOW MANY STAMPS
IT TOOK TO GET HER HERE.
>> I THINK SHE'S GORGEOUS.
I THINK SHE ACTUALLY LOOKS
A LOT BETTER IN PERSON
THAN SHE DOES IN HER PICTURES.
>> THIS IS
A MODELING COMPETITION,
AND I HAVE A MODEL LOOK
MUCH BETTER LOOK
THAN ANYBODY HAS HERE.
>> AAH!
(laughing)
>> MY GRANDMA HAS NO BOOTY.
MY MAMA HAS NO BOOTY.
SO THEREFORE, I HAVE NO BOOTY.
OKAY?
I'M A BLACK GIRL WITH NO ASS.
>> BUT YOU HAVE BOOBIES.
>> BUT I HAVE...
GUESS WHAT I HAVE?
I HAVE... (gasps)
>> AAH!
>> IT WAS, UM, I THINK THEY WERE
CHANEL OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT--
5 1/2 INCH--
>> NO, NO, NO. THAT WAS DIOR.
>> NO, IT WAS CHANEL.
>> SO A MAJOR SHOW THEY DON'T--
>> YOU DID
A CHANEL FASHION SHOW?
>> YEAH, IT WAS A LONG T--
A WHILE AGO.
IT WAS 5 1/2 INCH--
IN CLEVELAND.
>> IT WASN'T IN NEW YORK?
>> SHH. HEY, LET ME HEAR HER--
>> IN MIAMI? IN, LIKE, L.A.?
>> NO, I DID THE FASHION SHOW
FOR CHANEL.
I WAS TALKING
ABOUT A FASHION SHOW
THAT I DID FOR CHANEL,
AND SHE'S LIKE,
"NO, YOU DIDN'T."
SHE'S TRYING TO TELL ME--
SHE'S LIKE,
"NO, THOSE ARE DIOR,"
BLAH-BLAH-BLAH. I'M LIKE,
NO, I KNOW WHAT I WORE.
>> IT WAS NOT, LIKE, BIG, BIG...
(all talking at once)
>> SO I'M LIKE--
THAT'S WHY I'M LIKE--
I DON'T REMEMBER THOSE SHOES.
THERE ARE GIRLS
REALLY MASCULINE,
AND THEY JUST
NOT SUPPOSED TO BE HERE.
WHY ARE THEY HERE?
BUT I DON'T CARE.
THERE IS NO COMPETITION FOR ME
BECAUSE I CAN BEAT THEM ALL.
♪♪♪
>> GIVE ME SEXY! GIVE ME SEXY!
>> OH, WORK IT!
>> (cheering)
>> NO, I MOVE--I MOVED--
YEAH, I MOVED TO MARRY--
>> SO BASICALLY YOUR MARRIAGE--
SO BASICALLY HE'S THE ONE
THAT'S BRINGING YOU OVER HERE.
>> YEAH. YEAH. HE DID.
>> SO YOU WEREN'T
COMPLETELY BROKE,
'CAUSE YOU HAD YOUR HUSBAND
TO PRETTY MUCH TAKE CARE OF YOU.
THAT'S COOL.
>> UM, HE'S, LIKE, 40.
AND, UH...
>> (gasps)
>> MY DAD IS 41!
>> YEAH, WELL, I KNEW,
LIKE, "I LOVE YOU."
YOU KNOW,
"HI. MY NAME IS NATASHA."
>> (laughing)
>> WHAT IS THE PRINCESS LEIA?
I CAN'T SEE WHO YOU ARE
AS, LIKE, A MODEL.
>> OH, WE GOT IT, TYRA.
WE GOT IT.
>> TAKE IT OFF.
>> OKAY.
>> I'M READY.
>> NOW YOU'VE GOT
SOME LIP STAIN ON HERE...
>> UH-HUH.
I ALWAYS HAD, LIKE,
MAKEUP AS MY SIDE JOB.
I'VE KIND OF HAD EVERY JOB
YOU CAN IMAGINE AS FAR AS,
LIKE, DOING ANIMATION,
DOING ARTWORK.
SO LONG AS I COULD
EXPRESS MYSELF CREATIVELY,
LIKE, I WAS HAPPY.
>> WHO MOST INSPIRES YOU
ABOUT THIS FASHION INDUSTRY?
IS IT A DESIGNER? A MODEL?
>> IT WAS PROBABLY
A MIXTURE OF THE TWO.
UM, JOHN GALLIANO FROM
CHRISTIAN DIOR HOT COUTURE
IS MY ALL-TIME
FAVORITE INSPIRATION.
>> OKAY, WELL, GO PUT ON
YOUR HOT COUTURE SWIMSUIT.
>> MY DREAM IS TO HAVE
A GIRL THAT LOOKS LIKE ME
OPEN A MAGAZINE
AND SEE ME AND REALIZE,
"SHE HAS TATTOOS.
SHE DRESSES DIFFERENTLY."
>> HOW MANY TATTOOS DO YOU HAVE?
>> LAST TIME I COUNTED,
I THINK ALMOST 20.
>> 20 TATTOOS.
>> 'CAUSE I HAVE TATTOOS,
I DIDN'T THINK
THAT I COULD EVER DO THIS,
SO, LIKE, JUST BEING HERE
HAS ALREADY MADE, LIKE,
SO MANY MORE OF MY HOPES
AND DREAMS COME TRUE.
>> HEY, Y'ALL.
MY NAME IS SAMANTHA.
I'M 19 YEARS OLD,
AND I'M FROM PINSON, ALABAMA.
I'M PRETTY MUCH A COUNTRY GIRL.
I LIVE IN PINSON.
IT'S THE SMALLEST--
FEELS LIKE THE SMALLEST TOWN
IN THE COUNTRY.
LIKE, THE BIGGEST THING
THAT'S EVER HAPPENED THERE
WAS THE BUTTERBEAN FESTIVAL.
>> YOU HAVE AN INSECURITY.
WHAT'S YOUR INSECURITY?
>> LIKE, I'M MISSING A TOOTH
RIGHT THERE. (laughs)
>> SO YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU SHOULD DO?
DURING THE FESTIVAL,
GET A BUTTERBEAN.
>> JUST STICK IT UP IN THERE.
>> I'VE NEVER DONE
ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
I'VE NEVER MODELED.
I'VE NEVER WALKED
IN FRONT OF PEOPLE.
LIKE, IT'S REALLY,
REALLY STRANGE.
>> YOU JUST GOTTA GET
THE PEARLS OFF BEFORE WE TALK.
>> LET'S JUST DO THIS.
>> WHAT ARE THEY?
ARE THEY FOREVER 21
OR SOMETHING?
>> THEY SELL, LIKE,
HAIR WEAVES AND STUFF.
I'M FROM NEW YORK, THE BRONX.
WE DON'T RECOGNIZE THIRD PLACE.
WE DON'T RECOGNIZE SECOND.
WE ONLY SEE FIRST,
AND THAT'S
WHAT I'M HERE TO TAKE.
MY WEAVE--THIS IS A LONG STORY.
MY FRIEND--SHE HAD BORROWED IT
'CAUSE SHE WANTED TO SEE
HOW CURLY HAIR--
>> (laughs) WAIT A MINUTE.
>> YEAH.
>> WAIT A MINUTE. WAIT A MINUTE.
>> UH-HUH?
>> SHE BORROWED YOUR HAIR?
>> YEAH, BECAUSE WHEN YOU GUYS
CALLED,
I DIDN'T HAVE THE MONEY
TO GET A NEW WEAVE,
SO I TOLD HER I NEEDED IT BACK.
SO I SEWED IT BACK IN MY HAIR.
>> SO THIS IS THE WEAVE
THAT KEEPS ON GIVING.
>> NOW I HAVE, LIKE,
THESE TRACKS, LIKE, FALLING OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
SO IT'S, LIKE,
I WANNA PROVE TO THESE GIRLS,
LIKE, FROM THE BRONX,
YOU KNOW, WE CAN MAKE IT, TOO.
>> GORGEOUS, GREAT, STRONG FACE.
>> SHE'S A LITTLE SHORT,
AND SHE IS 5'7".
AND SHE LOOKS 5'7".
>> I AM DIONNE.
I'M 20 YEARS OLD.
I'M FROM MONTGOMERY, ALABAMA,
AND I'M A STUDENT
AT A.S.U. UNIVERSITY.
I'M A MOTHER.
I HAVE THREE SISTERS.
I'M A FORMER PIANIST.
I USED TO HAVE A PET TARANTULA.
HER NAME WAS SASSY,
BUT SHE DIED.
MY FAVORITE FOOD IS SPAGHETTI.
I LOVE, LOVE, LOVE, LOVE, LOVE
SPAGHETTI,
AND AFTER THAT COMES
T-BONE STEAKS AND SALAD.
MY FAVORITE COLOR IS BLUE.
>> WHOO! (laughs)
♪♪♪
>> I REALLY LIKE AUDREY HEPBURN.
I LOVE HER
IN "DINNER AT TIFFANY'S."
>> "DINNER AT TIFFANY'S"?
(laughs)
>> I'M SORRY. "LUNCH AT--"
"BRUNCH AT TIFFANY'S."
I'M SORRY. I'M SORRY.
>> "LUNCH AT TIFFANY'S"?
>> (laughing)
>> GUESS WHAT, HONEY?
>> GUESS WHAT?
>> IT WAS BREAKFAST.
>> BREAKFAST.
>> DON'T REALLY KNOW--I'M JUST
LIKE A BLANK SHEET OF PAPER.
>> AAH!
LORD, I JUST WANNA PRAISE JESUS.
♪♪♪
>> UM...
WHAT ELSE CAN I TELL YOU GUYS?
I LIKE TO SWIM.
I'M AFRAID TO GET IN, LIKE,
A BIG POOL OF WATER.
I'M NOT GOING PAST THE 8 FEET.
>> OH, HOLD ON A SECOND.
WHY YOU NOT GOING
PAST THE 8 FEET?
>> (laughing)
>> 'CAUSE I'M SCARED!
>> LET ME--LET ME CALL YOU BACK.
OKAY. BYE-BYE.
>> I LIKE TO WEAR MY HAIR LONG.
I LIKE TO WEAR, LIKE,
1B/30--THIS COLOR RIGHT HERE.
>> THAT'S 1B/30.
>> 1B/30.
>> OH, 1B IS THE BLACK SIDE...
>> MM-HMM.
>> OF THE COLOR, AND THE 30
IS KIND OF THE REDDISH.
>> YEAH.
>> I GOT YOU, GIRL. I GOT LIKE--
I GOT MORE 30 IN MINE.
>> I'M ACTUALLY IN SCHOOL NOW
STUDYING DENTISTRY.
MODELING AND DENTISTRY
ARE MY PASSIONS.
SOMETIMES I FIND MYSELF
DAYDREAMING LIKE,
"OH, I'M A SEXY MODEL,"
AND I'M PRACTICING
ON SOMEBODY'S TEETH
OR SOMETHING, SO... (laughs)
>> BRACE YOURSELVES, GIRLS.
>> I'M BACK!
>> (laughing)
>> YOU'RE SO CALM THIS SEASON.
>> I AM.
I'M ACTUALLY VERY CONFIDENT
THIS SEASON.
I AUDITIONED FOR CYCLE SEVEN.
GIRL, I WALK LIKE THIS
EVERY DAY DAY, ALL DAY.
UNFORTUNATELY, I DID NOT
MAKE IT INTO THE HOUSE.
I'M NOT GIVING UP.
>> YOU SHOULDN'T GIVE UP.
>> I'M COMING BACK.
>> YOU'RE COMING BACK?
YOU SEEM ALMOST TOO CALM.
THERE WAS SOME FIRE
THAT I LIKED BEFORE.
NOW YOU'RE ALMOST BECOMING
A LITTLE BORING, JASLENE.
>> OH, NO, GIRL.
DON'T MAKE ME TURN IT UP, GIRL.
>> TURN IT UP.
I WANNA SEE THE BEAUTY
THAT I LOVED LAST TIME.
>> I STILL HAVE
THE LATINA IN ME.
I'M STILL SPICY.
>> SHOW ME SOMETHING ELSE
THAT'S SPECIAL AND HOT
THAT I CAN REMEMBER
WHEN YOU WALK OUT OF THIS ROOM.
BUT NOT THAT JASLENE
CATALOG POSE.
>> YOU GUYS...
>> (grunt)
>> THERE YOU GO. WORK IT, GIRL.
>> AND, YES,
I STILL WALK LIKE THIS
ALL DAY, EVERY DAY.
>> OH!
>> JESSICA, 20.
INGLEWOOD, CALIFORNIA!
>> INGLEWOOD, UP TO NO GOOD,
HOLLA.
>> I WANNA BE IN THE HOUSE.
I WANNA TAKE PICTURES.
I WANNA GET DRESSED UP,
GLAMMED UP. I WANNA DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT WITH MY HAIR.
>> SO YOU SAY THAT YOU CAN HAVE
A LITTLE BIT OF A TEMPER.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> I START TALKING REAL FAST
IN A LOUD VOICE.
>> LIKE WHAT?
>> LIKE, "WHAT IS YOUR PROBLEM?"
DI-DI-DI-DI-DI-DUH.
I START TALKING LIKE...
>> JESSICA, YOU THINK
YOU'RE ALL THAT, BUT YOU REALLY
ARE NOT, YOU KNOW?
AND "INGLEWOOD, UP TO NO GOOD"?
BABY, I'M THE ORIGINAL
INGLEWOOD. HOLLA RIGHT HERE.
>> INGLEWOOD IS ALL THAT,
AND I REPRESENT INGLEWOOD.
DON'T YOU TELL ME I'M NOT THAT,
'CAUSE I AM
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
DON'T YOU EVEN GO THERE WITH ME.
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, BUT I'M ABOUT TO
KICK YOUR BUTT, AND THEN--
>> YOU CAN'T DO NOTHING TO ME.
I DARE YOU TO PUT
YOUR... HANDS ON ME.
>> OOH!
>> TYRA-FY ME, BABY!
TYRA-FY ME. (laughs)
>> HELLO.
TYRA, OH, MY GOD! TYRA'S HERE.
>> HI.
>> RENEE.
I'M 20, AND I'M FROM MAUI.
>> YOU JUMP OVER THE OCEAN
TO GET HERE?
>> NO, I'M ACTUALLY
LIVING WITH MY MOM
IN PALM SPRINGS RIGHT NOW.
MY HUSBAND'S OVER THERE,
TRYING TO MAKE SOME MONEY--
>> YOU'RE MARRIED?
>> YEAH.
>> AND HOW'S MARRIED LIFE LIKE
FOR SUCH A YOUNG GIRL?
>> IT'S GOOD. I MEAN, I'M AWAY
FROM MY HUSBAND RIGHT NOW,
AND I HAVE MY 7-MONTH-OLD BABY.
>> YOU JUST HAD A BABY?
LOOK AT YOUR STOMACH.
>> MY SON IS MY WORLD.
IN DOING THIS,
IT'S GONNA GIVE ME STRENGTH
AND IT'S GONNA GIVE ME
EVEN MORE DETERMINATION.
I JUST WANNA MAKE LIFE FOR HIM
TEN TIMES BETTER
THAN WHAT IT WAS FOR ME.
>> SO YOU DESCRIBE YOURSELF
AS A CATTY PERSON.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> I'M NOT A COMPLETE BITCH
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT,
BUT IF I HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY,
I'M GONNA SAY IT.
I DO WANT THESE GIRLS TO KNOW
THAT IF THEY GET IN MY WAY,
I WILL PLOW THEM OVER,
BECAUSE I TAKE NO PRISONERS.
>> IT'S ALL, LIKE, COATED.
>> I'M A BURPER, GUYS.
I'M NOT LIKE A...
(imitates burp)
I'M A FARTER. I'M, LIKE, A...
>> I BURP, AND I'M NOT OFFENDED
WHEN ANYONE ELSE LIKE--
>> LET'S HAVE A CONTEST.
>> IT USED TO BE
ABLE TO BURP THE A-B-C's.
>> I THINK THAT MODELS
SHOULD BE THEMSELVES.
>> WAIT, WHAT?
>> AAH!
>> KATHLEEN WAS, UM,
SAYING THAT SHE LIKES TO BURP.
SHE WAS LIKE...
(Brooklyn accent) "I DON'T CARE.
IF IT'S IN ME,
I'M GONNA BURP, RIGHT?
I'M GONNA JUST BE, LIKE..."
(imitates burp)
>> WHO CARES IF WE BURP OR FART?
>> I WAS BORN
IN A DIFFERENT PLACE
THAN YOU GIRLS.
>> YEAH, I BURPED,
AND YOU TELL ME, "OH, YOU THINK
MODELS SHOULD ACT--"
>> NATASHA SAID...
(imitates Russian accent) "WELL,
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE A LADY.
MODELS DON'T BURP."
>> NO, I'M NORMAL.
I DON'T KNOW--
MAYBE YOU'RE NOT NORMAL,
AND I'M TIRED OF YOU TELLING ME
BAD STUFF ABOUT ME, OKAY?
>> I'M SO OVER
YOU BEING A KNOW-IT-ALL.
I WAS JUST TRYING TO BE MYSELF
AND HAVE FUN,
AND SHE TRIED TO MAKE ME
LOOK STUPID, AND I'M NOT ABOUT
TO LET SOMEBODY DO THAT TO ME.
>> I'M NOT GONNA APOLOGIZE
BECAUSE YOU ACTUALLY
WERE CALLING ME "BITCH"
RIGHT HERE
IN FRONT OF EVERYBODY.
>> I'LL SAY GOOD-BYE TO YOU.
>> I DON'T WANT
TO HEAR YOU ANYMORE.
>> YOU'RE DONE. YOU'RE DONE.
>> AND YOU CAN GO AWAY.
>> DONE, DONE, DONE, DONE, DONE.
>> I'M NICE GIRL. I... (laughs)
>> OKAY, CAN WE VOTE ON THAT?
IF I COULD
TELL NATASHA SOMETHING,
IT WOULD BE, I'M NOT TAKING
CRAP FROM ANYBODY,
THAT I'M HERE FOR A REASON.
I'M HERE FOR A PURPOSE,
AND THAT'S TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
NOT TO HAVE YOU TRY AND TELL ME
HOW TO LIVE MY LIFE.
♪♪♪
>> HELLO! WHAT'S HAPPENING?
OH, MY GOD!
IT'S TYRA BANKS
AND MISS J. AND MR. JAY.
>> AND PULL YOUR SHIRT UP.
>> HOW ARE YOU GUYS DOING TODAY?
>> (laughs) YOUR SHIRT...
>> WHOO!
THAT'S MY BIKINI.
>> TELL ME ABOUT, UM, DARTMOUTH.
YOU'RE AN IVY LEAGUE GIRL.
>> I PLAYED BASKETBALL
MY FIRST TWO YEARS AT DARTMOUTH.
UM, DIDN'T REALLY THINK--
AM I BUSTING OUT? OKAY. (laughs)
LET ME HANDLE THAT. (giggles)
DARTMOUTH IS
AN ALL-WHITE SCHOOL.
I CAME IN AS A BLACK FRESHMAN,
AND, YOU KNOW...
>> THAT SOUNDS LIKE
THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
>> MM-HMM.
>> SO HOW WOULD YOU HANDLE THAT?
>> I KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GONNA TELL ME.
I KNOW THEY'RE GONNA TELL ME
I'M TOO FAT. I KNOW THAT
THEY'RE GONNA TELL ME
THAT I'M A PLUS-SIZE MODEL,
AND PLUS-SIZE MODELS
CANNOT HANDLE
THE HIGH FASHION INDUSTRY,
BUT I PLAN TO REVAMP THAT.
THAT NEEDS TO BE REVAMPED.
I'M A PLUS-SIZE MODEL
BECAUSE I'M CURVACEOUS,
AND BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
I GOT A LITTLE BIT MORE
MEAT ON MY BONES THAN THEY DO.
BUT I'M NOT FAT.
I THINK THAT I'M GORGEOUS--
AS GORGEOUS OR EVEN MORE
AS EVERYONE ELSE.
LIKE, BACK HOME,
I'M REGULAR SIZE. (laughs)
>> WOW. IT IS SO AMAZING
TO SEE YOUR FACE.
>> WHY ARE YOU CRYING?
>> 'CAUSE I'M SO EXCITED AND--
>> WOULD HAVE NEVER TAKEN YOU
FOR SOMEONE WHO WOULD CRY.
TELL US WHY YOU'RE UPSET.
>> OH, WOW. OKAY.
BECAUSE I CAME INTO THIS
NOT UNDERSTANDING
WHY I WAS CHOSEN AT ALL.
I'M NOT LIKE,
"OKAY, I'M THE HOTTEST THING
IN THE WORLD.
LOOK AT ME."
YOU KNOW?
I DON'T FOLLOW, LIKE,
THE DRUMBEAT OF EVERYONE ELSE.
(laughs)
>> WHAT NATIONALITY ARE YOU?
>> UM, MY MOM'S
AFRICAN-AMERICAN,
AND MY DAD IS GERMAN.
HE'S JEWISH.
>> YOU'RE HALF-BLACK?
>> YEAH.
>> THAT WAS SOME STRONG D.N.A.
ON YOUR DADDY'S SIDE.
>> PEOPLE ARE SO PREOCCUPIED
WITH ALL THESE, LIKE,
DIFFERENCES IN EACH OTHER
THAT WE DON'T, LIKE,
FOCUS ON WHAT QUALITIES
WE HAVE IN COMMON.
LIKE, I DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT I CONSIDER MYSELF.
I'VE JUST, LIKE,
SETTLED FOR BEING AMERICAN.
>> HEY.
>> HI.
>> MY NAME IS DIANA.
I'M 21 YEARS OLD,
AND I'M FROM GARFIELD,
NEW JERSEY.
>> NOW, DIANA,
YOU TOLD US IN BOOT CAMP
YOU WANTED TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL WHY?
TELL TYRA.
>> I WANNA BE
THE FIRST PLUS-SIZE GIRL TO WIN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
IT IS MY GOAL TO BE
THE FIRST PLUS-SIZE GIRL TO WIN,
BECAUSE I THINK IT WOULD
MAKE A REALLY GOOD STATEMENT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
BUT YOUR DAD HAS TOLD YOU
SOME THINGS
THAT WERE DIS--DISCOURAGING.
>> I USED TO BE SKINNY,
AND THEN, YOU KNOW,
JUST STARTED GAINING WEIGHT.
AND HE WOULD JUST SAY, LIKE,
MEAN THINGS TO ME.
>> WHAT KIND OF THINGS
WOULD HE SAY?
>> "OH, STOP EATING.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO FIT THROUGH THE DOOR."
OR, YOU KNOW, JUST, LIKE, THINGS
THAT WERE SO UNNECESSARY.
FINALLY, LIKE, "LISTEN.
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT ANYMORE.
LIKE, 'CAUSE IT'S NOT COOL,
AND YOU REALLY DO
HURT MY FEELINGS.
AND I AM BEAUTIFUL,
NO MATTER WHAT YOU SAY,
SO STOP."
>> HOW DOES IT FEEL BEING CALLED
PLUS-SIZE OR FULL-FIGURED,
WHEN I'M LOOKING AT YOU,
AND YOU JUST HAVE
A BEAUTIFUL BODY?
>> RIGHT. I MEAN,
I DON'T WANNA BE, LIKE,
YOU KNOW, STICK-SKINNY,
BECAUSE I LOVE WHO I AM,
AND I LOVE MY BODY.
SINCE I AM PLUS-SIZE,
I DON'T THINK
A LOT OF THE GIRLS REALIZE
THAT I AM THEIR COMPETITION.
I'M KIND OF HOPING
THAT THEY ARE KIND OF LIKE,
"OH, I DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT HER." YOU KNOW?
SO I CAN KIND OF SNEAK
UNDER THE RADAR.
>> MY NAME IS FELICIA.
I AM 19,
AND I'M FROM HOUSTON, TEXAS.
>> IS THAT WHY YOU HAVE
BEYONCé'S HAIR COLOR?
>> OH, MY GOD.
EVERYBODY'S BEEN CALLING ME
"BABY TYRA."
I'VE HAD PEOPLE COME UP TO ME
AT WORK AND SAY,
"SHE LOOKS LIKE TYRA BANKS.
YOU LOOK LIKE TYRA BANKS."
I HAVE THE GIRLS HERE
CALLING ME "BABY TYRA."
>> SO YOU SAY
YOU'RE NOT INTIMIDATED
BY THE OTHER GIRLS HERE.
>> TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH,
I CAN PIN SOME OF THEM
THAT I KEEP MY EYE ON.
FOR EXAMPLE, JASLENE--
HER WALK--SHE BE GETTING IT.
LIKE, OKAY, I HAVE TO WATCH HER.
MELISSA--WITH THE LOOKS--
I HAVE TO WATCH HER.
THE REST OF THEM...
THEY'RE JUST COOL TO TALK TO.
TYRA KNOWS
WHAT SHE'S LOOKING FOR
AND WHAT SHE'S NOT,
BUT I BELIEVE
I'M NOT GONNA GET CUT.
>> WELL, THEN,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
♪ MY SKIRT IS SHORT ♪
♪ MY BACK TOO TIGHT ♪
♪ MY BOOTY SHAKE ♪
♪ LEFT, LEFT, LEFT ♪
>> I GOTTA ASK Y'ALL THIS,
AND Y'ALL MAY THINK
THIS IS AN IGNORANT QUESTION,
BUT WHO'S--WHO HERE
ARE THE PLUS-SIZE MODELS
AND WHO ARE THE NORMAL ONES?
LIKE, THERE ARE SOME
THAT ARE ON THE LINE, LIKE--
>> WHITNEY.
>> SEE, I DIDN'T KNOW WHERE THE
LINE WAS.
>> BELOW A 12?
>> DIANA AND WHITNEY COULD BE,
LIKE, BIG COMPETITION,
AND THESE GIRLS
ARE NOT REALIZING THAT.
DIANA COULD BRING IT, LIKE,
BETTER THAN A SKINNY GIRL CAN.
YOU NEVER KNOW.
GUYS, FOR REAL?
>> WE DON'T WANNA GO HOME,
DO WE?
WE WANNA STAY HERE, EVERYBODY.
I DON'T WANNA NOBODY TO GO.
>> WHO'S TOP MODEL? WHOO!
♪♪♪
>> THIS IS THAT PART
THAT I ABSOLUTELY HATE.
>> WE BOTH HATE.
>> BUT...
>> WE DO HAVE TO MAKE
OUR FIRST CUT.
>> I QUIT MY JOB TO COME HERE,
SO I'M TAKING
A REALLY BIG CHANCE.
BUT I'M GONNA GET IN THAT HOUSE
AND I'M GONNA SHOW THEM
WHAT I HAVE.
>> SO BEHIND US IN THE ROOM
AT THE END OF THE HALL,
THERE ARE GIFT BAGS.
>> AND IN THOSE GIFT BAGS,
YOU WILL FIND...
>> AN INVITATION
TO THE MARC ECKO FASHION PARTY.
>> EVERY TIME THEY SAY
THE WORD "ELIMINATION,"
I'M LIKE, "SHUT UP, PLEASE!
DON'T SAY THAT."
I FEEL LIKE BUTTERFLIES ARE,
LIKE, DESTROYING MY STOMACH
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S CRAZY.
>> IF YOU FIND YOUR PHOTO,
THAT MEANS YOU HAVE TO
GET DRESSED ON THE SPOT
AND GET READY
TO GO TO THAT PARTY.
>> AAH!
>> AT EVERY FASHION PARTY,
THERE ARE PHOTOGRAPHERS,
AND THEY WILL BE
SNAPPING PHOTOS OF YOU.
AND YOU NEVER KNOW
WHO'S GONNA SEE THOSE PHOTOS.
BUT THOSE 20 INVITATIONS
REPRESENT THE YOUNG GIRLS
CONTINUING ON
IN THE COMPETITION.
>> (booming voice)
HOW READY ARE YOU?
>> READY, MA'AM!
(cheers and applause)
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO WE'RE GONNA COUNT YOU DOWN.
THREE...
TWO...
ONE!
>> (screaming)
>> GO! GO!
>> GO!
♪♪♪
>> AAH!
>> OH, MY GOD!
THIS IS MY DREAM,
AND GOD KNOWS,
I WANT THIS SO BAD.
>> (screaming)
>> AAH!
>> OH, MY GOD. I'M SHAKING.
>> MY BODY'S, LIKE, SCREAMING
AND JUMPING UP AND DOWN.
I'M LIKE, YOU KNOW, IT IS ON.
I AM HERE,
AND THE GAME HAS STARTED.
>> ONE MORE STEP,
AND I'M IN.
I'M GONNA BE
THE FIRST LATINA TO WIN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> (screaming)
>> I'M ECSTATIC,
AND I'M REPPING
WITH ANOTHER PLUS-SIZE MODEL.
YOU KNOW? THERE ARE TWO OF US.
>> YOU HAVE MY NUMBER, THOUGH,
HONEY.
>> I DON'T CARE ABOUT IT.
>> WHOO!
>> PERSONALITY MEANS
MORE THAN LOOKS, APPARENTLY.
>> JAEL--SHE DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT BEING HERE,
AND ALL SHE DOES
IS ACT LIKE AN IDIOT.
AND SHE BEAT ME OUT.
AND THAT MAKES ME SO ANGRY.
I JUST WANNA GO PUNCH HER.
>> I FEEL BAD FOR THE GIRLS THAT
DIDN'T MAKE IT, BUT HONESTLY,
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
>> NO, I NEED
TO GO BACK TO WORK.
>> AND IF THEY COULDN'T CUT IT,
THEY COULDN'T CUT IT.
SO I WAS GLAD TO SEE THEM GO.
>> (cheering)
♪♪♪
>> HEY, YOU GUYS LOOK ALL RIGHT.
I CAN'T EVEN FRONT.
YOU GUYS LOOK GOOD.
>> OH, MY GOD.
I'M AT THE HOTTEST SPOT IN L.A.
RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH.
>> JERMAINE DUPRI--
HE DRESSES BADASS,
JUST LIKE JANET.
HE'S FLY. HE REALLY IS.
>> HOW TALL ARE YOU, ACTUALLY?
>> I'M 6'1".
>> A BUNCH OF TALL GIRLS
INSIDE OF... HOUSE.
>> IT'S ALL GOOD.
>> I LOVE THIS.
>> GIVE ME THAT.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> THIS PHOTO IS VERY IMPORTANT.
YOU MAY BE GETTING ELIMINATED
OFF OF THIS PHOTO.
>> WHOO. OKAY.
OKAY.
READY?
>> I THINK THAT
I CAN DEFINITELY WIN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS OUR "PUMP ME UP,"
AND I'M HAPPY AND I'M DANCING.
>> (cheering)
>> TASHA SHOULD
TURN IT DOWN A NOTCH.
SHE WAS REALLY DANCING, LIKE,
SO OUT THERE.
>> READY? THERE WE GO.
GORGEOUS.
GIVE ME ANOTHER ONE.
>> WHAT KIND OF MODEL ARE YOU?
>> PLUS-SIZE.
>> YOU'RE A PLUS-SIZE MODEL?
>> YES, SIR.
>> GORGEOUS.
>> I'M JUST GONNA HAVE
TO WAIT AND SEE IF THEY DO WANT
TWO PLUS-SIZE GIRLS,
'CAUSE THAT'S NEVER HAPPENED
BEFORE. IF THEY ONLY WANT ONE,
I'M PRAYING TO GOD THAT IT'S ME.
>> YOU'RE MY LAST GIRL TONIGHT.
>> SAVED THE BEST FOR LAST.
>> I THINK TYRA'S GONNA USE
THESE PICTURES,
SO IT'S LIKE,
I'VE REALLY GOTTA KICK ASS
IN THIS PICTURE.
>> I PERSONALLY CAN'T PICK OUT
WHO I THINK IS GONNA MOVE ON,
AND NOW I THINK MY NERVES
ARE EVEN MORE, LIKE, ON EDGE,
SIMPLY BECAUSE I KNOW NOW THAT,
YOU KNOW,
IT'S ALL UP IN THE AIR.
♪♪♪
>> MY TWO LOVELY J's,
THIS IS THE EIGHTH TIME
WE HAVE HAD TO DO
THIS DELIBERATION.
WE'VE GOTTA TAKE 20 GIRLS
AND NARROW THEM DOWN TO 13.
>> NOT AN EASY JOB.
>> DO YOU HAVE YOUR FAVORITES?
>> I DO HAVE MY FAVORITES.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> I DO, BUT I'M NOT SPEAKING
ABOUT IT, 'CAUSE EVERY TIME
I SPEAK ABOUT MY FAVORITES,
THEY DISAPPEAR.
>> THEY DISAPPEAR? (laughs)
>> (laughs) ALL RIGHT.
WELL, LET'S AT LEAST
START WITH BRITTANY.
>> AAH!
>> (laughs)
>> BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
LOOK AT THAT BOOT CAMP SHOT.
THAT TELLS ME
THERE IS SUCH POTENTIAL THERE.
>> CASSANDRA.
>> I LOVE HOW SHE LOOKS,
ACTUALLY, AT THE PARTY PICTURES.
>> I THINK THAT THAT PICTURE
LOOKS LIKE A REAL MODEL.
AND EVEN THOUGH SHE GOT HER WIG
SEWN TO HER HEAD,
AT LEAST SHE KNEW TO SEW IT
IN THE RIGHT SPOT.
>> (Russian accent) NATASHA.
>> (speaks in Russian)
I LOVE HER FACE.
I LOVE HER LOOK.
I JUST WISH
SHE WAS A BIT TALLER.
>> DIANA... I THINK
DIANA IS THE PERFECT EXAMPLE
OF A FULL-FIGURED MODEL.
>> DOES SHE HAVE WHAT IT TAKES
TO STAND
THROUGH THE COMPETITION?
>> WHITNEY... LOOK HOW PRETTY
SHE LOOKS IN THAT PARTY PHOTO.
SHE IS GLOWING.
>> FULL-FIGURED GIRL
TO BE SO FULL OF LOVING HERSELF.
>> IF SHE LOVES HERSELF,
THEN THAT MEANS THAT I CAN LOVE
MYSELF TOO.
>> I DO THINK THAT WHITNEY
IS GOING TO SERVE IT UP
OVER DIANA.
>> DIONNE... SO WHAT DO YOU
THINK ABOUT DIONNE?
BECAUSE I LOVE THESE FLOWERS.
THEY LOOK SO PRETTY,
AND OH, MY GOD,
I JUST GOT MY HAIR WEAVE DONE.
>> BUT I HAVE THEM, TOO.
>> I LOVE THAT
SHE'S GOT DIARRHEA OF THE MOUTH,
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE TO HEAR
IN A PHOTOGRAPH.
>> BETHANY.
>> I LIKE BETHANY.
I DO LIKE HER FACE.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THAT PARTY PHOTOGRAPH,
SHE DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO
REALLY POSE FOR A PHOTOGRAPHER
WHEN SHE'S SUPPOSED TO SHOW.
>> FELICIA.
>> I LIKE FELICIA.
AND I DO SEE
A SLIGHT SIMILARITY TO YOU.
>> I DO SEE
A LITTLE HIDDEN SOMETHING,
LIKE SHE'S GOT
SOMETHING UP HER SLEEVE.
>> HEATHER.
>> I THINK SHE'S GREAT
FOR CATALOG, COMMERCIAL-LEVEL.
SHE COULD BE A COMMERCIAL MODEL.
>> OKAY.
>> JAEL.
>> I THINK
JAEL HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO WALK INTO A ROOM AND COMMAND
THE ATTENTION OF THE ROOM.
>> SHE LOOKS LIKE
SHE JUST GOT OUT OF JAIL, TOO.
>> KATHLEEN... LOOK AT
THAT PICTURE. SHE IS WORKING IT.
>> YES!
>> LOOK AT THE PERFECTION
OF THAT RED SHOE.
THAT'S A STUNNING PICTURE.
>> NEXT IS MELISSA,
BUT, YOU GUYS,
WE NEED TO HURRY UP,
BECAUSE MY FRIEND TASHA--
SHE NEEDS HER HAIR BACK.
>> I DIDN'T HAVE THE MONEY
TO GET A NEW WEAVE,
SO I TOLD HER I NEEDED IT BACK.
>> I AM SORRY I HAVE TO HONESTLY
DEFEND MELISSA,
BECAUSE LOOK AT THAT PARTY
SNAPSHOT.
>> SHE HAS, LIKE,
A TOUGH KIND OF EXTERIOR TO ME.
I FEEL LIKE
IT'S, LIKE, A PROTECTION.
RENEE. LOOK AT HER POSING
IN THE--AT THE PARTY--
IT'S GOT SOME TYPE OF ANGLE
AND AWARENESS OF HER BODY.
>> TYRA, YOU TELL ME
THE LAST TIME
YOU WERE AT A PARTY
AND YOU POSED LIKE THAT
FOR A PHOTOGRAPHER.
>> I DO THAT EVERY PARTY.
>> NO, YOU DON'T.
>> I WILL PULL OUT
SOME PARTY PICTURES ON YOUR BUTT
RIGHT NOW OF US ACTING A FOOL
AT A PARTY. CLICK. RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH, BUT THAT--
>> CLICK. YEAH, AND THAT ONE.
CLICK! THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SAMANTHA.
>> I LIKE SAMANTHA,
JUST BECAUSE THERE'S SOMETHING
A LITTLE BIT DEVILISH ABOUT HER.
>> DOESN'T IT REMIND YOU
OF SOMETHING JANICE DICKINSON
WOULD HAVE SHOT BACK IN THE DAY?
>> IT DOES KIND OF LOOK LIKE
AN OLD JANICE DICKINSON COVER.
I MEAN, SHE HAS 85 OF THEM.
>> 127.
>> IT WAS 132.
>> IT WAS A MILLION.
>> (both laugh)
>> SARAH.
>> LOOK.
>> (laughs) WHY?
BECAUSE EVERY TIME
YOU GUYS REALLY LIKE SOMEBODY,
I'M LIKE,
"UNH-UNH. NOT GETTING IN."
>> LOOK AT HER PARTY SHOT.
I AM SORRY,
SARAH IS THE ONLY GIRL
THAT LOOKED LIKE
A FASHION MODEL AT A PARTY
GETTING A SNAPSHOT.
>> JASLENE--
SHE WAS THE GIRL
THAT CAME LAST SEASON,
BUT SHE'S BACK,
AND SHE SAYS,
"WITH A VENGEANCE."
>> I'M ACTUALLY VERY CONFIDENT
THIS SEASON, VERY STRONG.
>> SHE WAS REALLY HOLDING BACK,
I THOUGHT,
WHEN SHE CAME IN TO SEE US.
>> HOLDING BACK TOO MUCH.
>> DO YOU SEE YOUR WINNER
IN THAT GROUP OF GIRLS?
♪♪♪
>> THIS IS THE EIGHTH TIME
THAT I HAVE DONE THIS,
AND IT WOULD SEEM LIKE
SINCE IT'S THE EIGHTH TIME
IT GETS EASIER.
BUT I HAVE TO SAY,
THIS IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE HARDEST PARTS,
BECAUSE YOU ALL
WERE SEMIFINALISTS
AND GOT FLOWN
FROM ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
TO COME HERE
AND GOT NARROWED DOWN TO 20.
BUT THERE'S ONLY 13 SPOTS LEFT.
FOR SEVEN OF YOU,
THIS IS AS FAR
AS YOU'RE GOING TO COME.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL IS...
>> NATASHA.
>> (gasps) MY GOD!
OH, MY GOD!
(crying)
>> HOW DO YOU SAY,
"I AM SO HAPPY RIGHT NOW"
IN RUSSIAN?
>> ALL RIGHT. GO TAKE YOUR SPOT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE NEXT NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL IS...
KATHLEEN!
>> AAH!
TYRA, DON'T LIE TO ME, PLEASE!
>> (laughing)
>> I'M TELLING THE TRUTH,
MISS KATHLEEN!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> NEXT NAME...
SARAH.
>> OH!
(laughs)
>> CASSANDRA.
>> GO, GIRL.
>> HELLS, YEAH.
>> RENEE.
HOW YOU FEELING, RENEE?
YOU THINKING ABOUT YOUR BABY?
>> (sobbing) YES!
>> 'CAUSE MAMA JUST MIGHT BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
>> MAMA IS
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
SAMANTHA!
>> (gasps)
>> "1B/30," GIRL!
>> YEAH! 1B/30!
YAY!
>> (laughing)
>> THE NEXT NAME IS...
WHITNEY!
>> (gasps) THANK YOU.
>> (exhales deeply)
>> (crying)
THANK YOU, JESUS.
>> BRITTANY.
>> REALLY? (laughs)
I'M SORRY.
>> FOUR GIRLS LEFT.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL IS...
FELICIA.
>> AAH! JESUS. OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD. OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD. (laughs)
>> THREE NAMES LEFT.
JAEL.
>> OH, GOD! I GET TO COME!
>> (laughing)
>> I LOVE YOU GUYS SO MUCH!
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND!
I GET TO COME!
>> (cheering)
>> I GET TO COME!
>> THREE NAMES LEFT.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL...
JASLENE!
>> AAH!
OH, MY GOD!
(speaks Spanish)
OH, MY GOD. OH, MY GOD.
>> YES, GIRL!
>> OH, MY...
THANK YOU SO MUCH, TYRA!
THANK YOU.
>> GIVE IT TO ME!
>> (laughing)
>> AAH!
>> I ONLY HAVE ONE NAME LEFT,
AND THIS ONE GIRL WILL JOIN
THESE 12 VERY HAPPY GIRLS
OVER HERE
AND WILL BE THE LAST GIRL
THAT WILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE LAST NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL IS...
>> DIANA!
>> (screaming)
>> OH, MY GOD!
OH, MY GOD.
WHY DO YOU DO THAT TO ME?
>> (laughs)
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
IN "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
HISTORY THAT
THERE ARE TWO PLUS-SIZE GIRLS
IN THIS COMPETITION.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> (sobbing)
>> THANKS, GIRLS.
YOU GUYS STAY STRONG, OKAY?
YOU GOT THIS FAR,
SO THAT MEANS YOU DO HAVE
SOME MODELING POTENTIAL.
AND THIS IS GONNA HURT,
AND YOU'RE GONNA CRY TONIGHT,
AND YOU MIGHT CRY FOR WEEKS.
>> I AM STRONG.
I'M FROM NEW YORK. I'M TOUGH.
TYRA LIKED ME, THEN, YOU KNOW,
SO MANY MORE PEOPLE OUT THERE
ARE GONNA LIKE ME.
>> YOU GOT THIS FAR,
SO THAT MEANS
THERE IS SOMETHING THERE,
AND KEEP TRYING.
>> I WANTED THIS SO BAD.
TO GO HOME AND...
IT'S HEARTBREAKING.
I STILL HAVE A DESIRE TO MODEL.
I'LL ALWAYS HAVE
A DESIRE TO MODEL.
>> (cheering)
>> MY NAME IS TYRA.
>> HEY!
>> AND I SHAKE IT!
>> AND I DO THE A.N.T.M...
>> PLUS-SIZE WOMEN--
WE JUST HAVE TO REPRESENT
FOR THEM,
AND WE'RE GONNA DO IT.
WE'RE JUST GONNA KICK ASS.
>> MY NAME IS KATHLEEN!
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO PINCH ME
RIGHT NOW,
'CAUSE THIS IS LIKE
"ALICE IN WONDERLAND."
OF COURSE
I'M GONNA WIN THIS COMPETITION.
I'M NOT A GIRL THAT GIVES UP.
>> A.N.T.M. UP!
>> (grunts)
DON'T GO AWAY. THE SECOND PART
OF OUR TWO HOUR PREMIER IS
NEXT...
>> THE GIRLS
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING
WITH THEIR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT.
>> DOES THIS SPEAK TO YOU?
PRO-CHOICE?
>> BUT SOME JUST CAN'T CUT IT.
>> JUST CONNECT WITH THE CAMERA.
>> THE EXCITEMENT CONTINUES
AS THE GIRLS EMBRACE
THEIR NEW POSH PAD,
BUT NOT EACH OTHER.
>> THERE IS, LIKE,
TONS OF OTHER GIRLS
WHO WOULD DIE TO BE HERE.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW ME.
HOW DARE YOU?
>> WHO WILL BE
THE FIRST TO GO HOME?
♪♪
(SCREAMING)
OH MY GOD!
>> I HAVE A LEG UP
ON OTHER PEOPLE
BECAUSE I DO HAVE
MODELING EXPERIENCE IN THE PAST,
AND I AM A PHOTOGRAPHER.
>> I'M EXPERIENCING
THIS AMAZING OPPORTUNITY.
I'M NOT FOCUSED ON, LIKE,
ANY COMPETITION
WITH THE OTHER GIRLS.
I'D LIKE TO BE
EVERYONE'S FRIEND.
>> MODEL WALK
DOWN HOLLYWOOD BOULEVARD!
I WAS BORN AND RAISED
IN BROOKLYN.
I NEVER DID ANY MODELING.
I'M HERE TO LEARN,
'CAUSE I WANT IT SO BAD.
LIKE, I WILL DO ANYTHING FOR IT,
YOU KNOW?
AS WE WERE WALKING,
WE SEE THIS, LIKE,
MOTORCYCLE THING
WITH, LIKE, THIS BIG SIGN
IN THE BACK OF IT.
>> AAH!
>> ALL OF A SUDDEN,
I LOOK UP AND I SEE MR. JAY
HOP OFF OF THIS SCOOTER.
I'M LIKE, "AAH! HEY, JAY!"
>> YOU GIRLS ARE THE FINAL 13!
>> WHOO!
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS,
RIGHT?
THAT MEANS ONE OF YOU
IS AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> NEXT TOP MODEL!
AAH!
>> LIKE TYRA,
ONE OF YOU IS GONNA BE
A HOUSEHOLD NAME
AND ROLE MODEL.
BUT BEING A TOP MODEL ISN'T
JUST ABOUT BEING A PRETTY FACE.
IT'S ABOUT MAKING A STATEMENT.
SO NOW ARE YOU GUYS READY
TO MAKE YOUR FIRST STATEMENT?
>> YEAH!
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS,
RIGHT?
THAT MEANS WE'RE OFF
TO OUR VERY FIRST PHOTO SHOOT.
>> AAH!
>> I'M GONNA WIN THIS WAR.
I'M GONNA TAKE HOME THE TITLE
OF AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> COME ON. LET'S GO.
>> AAH!
>> I WAS SHOCKED TO FIND OUT
ON OUR VERY FIRST DAY
WE WERE SHOOTING.
BUT I'M VERY READY
TO GET THE COMPETITION STARTED.
>> NOW WE'RE AT
OUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT,
AND REMEMBER,
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A STATEMENT.
KEEP IN MIND, FASHION IS
A REALLY POLITICAL WORLD
WHERE WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT KINDS
OF POLITICAL VIEWS.
WE HAVE ANTI-FUR,
PRO-FUR,
PRO-WAR,
ANTI-WAR.
I'M GONNA ASSIGN
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
A DIFFERENT POLITICAL VIEW.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU
TO SELL IT,
EVEN IF YOU DO
NOT AGREE WITH IT.
>> I THINK THAT IT'S REALLY NEAT
THAT OUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
WAS SUCH A POLITICAL STATEMENT,
'CAUSE I THINK IT TEACHES ME
THAT I NEED TO BE COMFORTABLE
IN WHATEVER I GET PUT IN.
>> ALL RIGHT, KATHLEEN,
YOU'RE GONNA BE ANTI-FUR.
>> (laughs)
>> BUT, BRITTANY,
YOU'RE GONNA BE THE OPPOSITE.
YOU'RE GONNA BE PRO-FUR.
NATASHA, YOU'RE PRO-CHOICE.
>> OH!
>> JAEL, YOU'RE PRO-LIFE.
>> UNH-UNH.
>> (laughs)
>> SARAH,
YOU BELIEVE IN LIFE IN PRISON.
JASLENE,
YOU BELIEVE
IN THE DEATH PENALTY.
FELICIA,
YOU ARE FOR STRAIGHT MARRIAGE.
NOW FOR GAY MARRIAGE,
WE HAD TO PAIR TWO OF YOU UP.
THAT'S WHITNEY AND SAMANTHA.
DIONNE,
YOU'RE GONNA BE THE VEGAN.
WHEREAS CASSANDRA,
YOU'RE JUST A GIRL
WHO LOVES TO EAT MEAT.
>> (laughs)
>> ALL RIGHT?
AND THEN OUR LAST TWO--
RENEE, YOU ARE ANTI-GUN.
DIANA, YOU ARE PRO-GUNS.
OKAY?
SO NOW WE'RE REALLY GONNA
LAY ON THE PRESSURE,
AND WE HAVE GOT
THE PERFECT PHOTOGRAPHER--
SOMEBODY WHO KNOWS NOT ONLY
HOW TO MAKE A STATEMENT,
BUT AN ENTRANCE.
I THINK YOU KNOW WHO THIS IS.
>> (screaming)
>> I THINK EVERY MODEL
WANTS TO DATE NIGEL BARKER,
'CAUSE HE'S SO TALL.
>> MR. NIGEL BARKER.
AND HE IS NOT ONLY
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY,
BUT HE'S GONNA BE YOUR JUDGE.
SO YOU GUYS
REALLY READY TO SELL IT?
>> YEAH!
>> SO LET'S GO UPSTAIRS.
LET'S DO THIS.
♪♪♪
>> REALLY BRING HER LIPS OUT...
RED MOUTH.
>> I NEED TO KNOW LIKE HOW DO
YOU DO ANTI-FUR.
LIKE, DO I LOOK AT THE FUR,
LIKE..UUHH.
I HATE FUR.
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> HE'S MY LITTLE ANGEL.
I HAVE MORE DETERMINATION
THAN ANY--ANY ONE OF THOSE
GIRLS,
BECAUSE I HAVE
A LOT MORE AT RISK HERE.
I HAVE A SON
THAT I NEED TO TAKE CARE OF.
YEAH.
I HAVEN'T GOT TO TALK TO HIM
YET, BUT.
HOPEFULLY SOON.
>> I'M VERY EXCITED
TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS,
FOR MY FAMILY.
I HAVE TO WIN THIS.
(COUGHS)
JAEL IS SICK,
LIKE, SHE HAS THIS NASTY COLD.
>> I HAVE A AH FEVER RIGHT NOW.
AND I FEEL THAT THIS MAY AFFECT
MY SHOOT TODAY.
>> I AM SUPPOSED TO BE PRO-FUR.
>> HAVE YOU EVER BEEN
TO A FASHION SHOW?
>> NO.
>> OKAY, NOW LET ME TELL YOU,
THE COVETED FRONT ROW IS IT.
AS YOU SEAT DOWN, YOU ARE GIVING
A LOOK ALL THE TIME.
LIKE A RED CARPET OF SOULS.
>> I DON'T REALLY HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH PRO-FUR,
BUT IT IS A LITTLE WEIRD
TO HAVE THE HEAD OF AN ANIMAL
ON MY SHOULDER.
THAT KIND OF CREEPED ME OUT
A LITTLE.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> NOW SNEAK A LITTLE SMILE
INTO YOUR EYES.
OPEN THE MOUTH A LITTLE BIT.
WHAT BRITTANY MANAGED TO DO WAS,
UH, HAVE THAT GREAT AIR
OF A SORT OF SLIGHT ARROGANCE,
WHICH WAS ACTUALLY
EXACTLY WHAT I WANTED.
THANK YOU.
>> MY THING TODAY IS ANTI-FUR.
LIKE, I HATE FUR.
ACTUALLY, I REALLY DO LIKE FUR.
I MEAN, IT MAKES YOU LOOK HOT.
>> WELL, YOU'RE--
I'M LIKE...
>> WELL, NO, NO, NO.
YOU'RE NOT WHIPPING PEOPLE.
PLAY WITH IT.
I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME
THAT SEXY VIBE--
>> LIKE I'M DESTROYING THE FUR?
>> YOU'RE--BUT THIS IS
STILL A FASHION SHOT.
>> I HATE FUR. (laughs)
>> GOOD.
COME 'ROUND TO ME A BIT...
WITH YOUR FACE, TOO.
NO.
THERE--NO.
PUT IT INSIDE.
JAY, WE NEED HELP.
>> WHAT ARE YOU THINKING,
KATHLEEN?
I WANNA KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON IN YOUR HEAD.
>> HIGH FASHION.
>> WHAT DOES "HIGH FASHION"
MEAN TO YOU?
>> SERIOUS LOOK, LIKE...
>> YOU'RE JUST
HOLDING THE BRUSH,
GIVING ME HIGH FASHION?
>> (laughs) OH, GOD!
>> YOU SEE WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> HE'S ASKING ME TO GIVE HIM
HIGH FASHION BUT THEN ALSO
SEND A MESSAGE ACROSS.
>> HOW ABOUT GRABBING
THAT PAINT CAN?
SO YOU'RE ACTUALLY
PROACTIVE IN THE SHOT.
YOU'RE NOT JUST SITTING
ON THE SHOT.
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> HE WANTS YOU
ACTIVELY PARTICIPATING
IN WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> OH, OKAY. OKAY.
>> I THINK KATHLEEN WAS
VERY CONFUSED BY THE WHOLE
ANTI-FUR KIND OF, UH, CONCEPT.
SHE ALSO DIDN'T EMBRACE
THAT IT WAS A POLITICAL VIEW.
THIS IS YOUR LAST
FEW FRAMES NOW.
REALLY GIVE IT TO ME.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> LAST FRAME.
THAT'S IT.
>> IT TOOK ME SO LONG
TO ACTUALLY FIND THAT EMOTION,
BUT I BELIEVE I
FOUND IT AT THE END.
>> I NEED YOU TO BRING ME
THAT LATINA FIRE.
>> ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
LET'S DO THIS.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> THAT LOOKS GREAT.
>> I WANNA STAND UP
FOR MOST LATINAS.
I'M GONNA MAKE SURE
I GIVE MY ALL,
AND I WANNA SHOW THEM
THAT A LATINA LIKE ME
CAN MAKE IT FAR.
>> THANK YOU. WELL DONE.
>> YOU HAVE THE KEYS, RIGHT?
>> THEY--THEY DON'T NEED KEYS.
>> OKAY, COOL.
>> (laughs) THEY'RE FAKE.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> IN THE PAST,
I'VE WORKED WITH
A LOT OF AMAZING PHOTOGRAPHERS.
I KNOW JAY KNOWS THAT.
HE'S EXPECTING
A LITTLE BIT MORE OUT OF ME.
>> DON'T JUST MAKE IT
TOO PRETTY.
HAVE A LITTLE SOMETHING
GOING ON IN YOUR EYES.
>> THAT WAS A BLAST.
>> I WAS ACTUALLY SURPRISED
HOW LITTLE I GOT OUT OF SARAH,
AND HER FACE DID NOTHING FOR ME.
SHE HAD ONE LOOK.
I THINK YOU COULD BE
A LITTLE KITSCH WITH IT,
A LITTLE FUNNY WITH IT.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> GUNS ARE BAD,
BUT SOMETIMES PEOPLE NEED IT
FOR PROTECTION.
AND IF YOU ARE RESPONSIBLE WITH
IT THEN I'M ALL FOR IT.
I LIKE TO SEE SOME ACTION.
>> TRY AND ACTUALLY JUMP.
>> DIANA DIDN'T COMMIT 100%,
AND IF YOU DON'T COMMIT
TO YOUR ACTION,
THE PHOTO'S GONNA FALL FLAT
EVERY TIME.
HOW YOU GUYS DOING?
>> GOOD.
>> (laughs) REALLY?
YOU DON'T LOOK SO--YOU'RE LIKE--
>> OH, MAN,
'CAUSE I KNOW THAT I COULD
BLOW THE TOP OFF OF THIS,
IF I'M NOT FEELING
I'M ABOUT TO PASS OUT
AND I'M NOT HAVING
COLD FLASHES FROM A FEVER.
I'M GONNA FIGURE OUT
HOW I CAN DO EVERYTHING
THAT I'M SUPPOSED TO BE DOING,
'CAUSE SOMETIMES I FEEL LIKE
I CAN HARDLY STAND UP.
>> I GUESS YOU MUST BE...
>> ANTI-GUN.
HAVE SOME FUN WITH IT.
VERY AT PEACE, NOT FIERCE.
EXACTLY.
>> YOU HAVE TO GET LONG NECK.
USE YOUR WHOLE BODY
WHEN YOU MODEL...
>> NOT JUST YOUR FACE.
>> OKAY.
>> IT WAS REALLY HARD FOR ME
TO, LIKE, TRY AND GET MYSELF
TO DO THE PEACEFUL,
BECAUSE IT'S, LIKE,
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY,
VERY HARD TO PORTRAY.
DOES THAT LOOK AWKWARD?
>> LET'S CHANGE--LET'S CHANGE--
YEAH, IT LOOKS A BIT WEIRD.
>> DO YOU FEEL VERY PASSIONATELY
ABOUT THAT?
>> NO.
I FEEL THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
>> OKAY.
FIND SOMETHING THAT YOU FEEL
THAT PASSIONATELY ABOUT,
THAT YOU WOULD BE CHAINED
TO A DOOR FOR.
IF IT DOESN'T SPEAK TO YOU HERE,
I'M NOT GONNA SEE IT HERE.
>> I'M GONNA LET MY EXCITEMENT
OUTWEIGH MY ILLNESS,
BECAUSE I'M NOT GONNA ALLOW
FEELING SICK
TO AFFECT MY SHOOT TODAY.
>> HAVE SOME EMOTION
AND REALLY BELIEVE IT
FOR THAT SPLIT MOMENT.
REALLY GIVE IT TO ME.
>> YOU HAVE,
IF ANYBODY HERE,
A LOT OF ENERGY.
GIVE ME LIKE... (groans)
LIKE, JUST REALLY GO THERE.
(camera shutter clicking)
>> THAT'S IT.
>> NERVES. ALL I SEE IS NERVES.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> I FEEL LIKE
I'M GONNA PASS OUT,
AND IT'S NOT OKAY, IS IT?
OH, MAN, I KNOW I COULD'VE
ROCKED IT SO MUCH BETTER
IF I WAS FULL OF ENERGY.
BUT, MM, I MESSED UP,
AND I FEEL REALLY BAD.
I'M NO EXCUSES TYPE OF GIRL,
YOU KNOW?
I STILL WANNA GIVE IT MY ALL.
>> OKAY, GO FOR IT.
>> WHOO!
>> PUSH WITH
YOUR STOMACH MUSCLES,
SO YOU PUSH IT.
>> I KNOW THAT JAEL
IS, YOU KNOW, ALL ABOUT BEING
BEST FRIENDS WITH EVERYBODY,
BUT, HEY, TO EACH HIS OWN.
I KNOW SHE'S NOT GONNA
WIN THIS COMPETITION.
>> (laughs)
>> GOOD JOB, GIRL.
>> JAEL--ONE SECOND SHE IS SICK,
AND ONE SECOND
SHE'S HULA HOOPING.
I'M NOT SURE IF IT WAS A PLOY
TO--IN CASE SHE DID BAD
OR IF SHE WAS JUST
PSYCHING HERSELF OUT.
>> WHOA.
>> DO YOU UNDERSTAND
THE MESSAGE?
>> YEAH. I'VE--I'M GETTING RID
OF THE BABY. BASICALLY, RIGHT?
>> WELL, IT'S YOUR CHOICE.
>> IT'S MY CHOICE, YES.
>> YOU'RE NOT GETTING RID
OF ANY BABY, I HOPE.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> LITTLE TOO MUCH.
THINK ABOUT THE MESSAGE AS WELL.
DON'T--DON'T MAKE IT
TOO KIND OF, LIKE,
ALL ABOUT MODELING.
>> I PREFER NOT GONNA
BE INVOLVED IN THE POLITICS.
I PREFER JUST, UH, BE A MODEL.
>> IF I HAD TO GIVE
YOU A REFERENCE--
IF I SAID KATE MOSS,
DOES THAT HELP YOU?
I FEEL LIKE
SHE WOULD WORK THAT WALL.
>> NATASHA DIDN'T SEEM TO HAVE
ANY IDEA AS TO WHERE I WAS
OR WHERE THE LIGHTS WERE,
AND SHE WOULD JUST FACE IN
ALL KINDS OF STRANGE DIRECTIONS.
>> MY PHOTO SHOOT
IS GAY MARRIAGE.
I THOUGHT THAT
WAS PRETTY INTERESTING,
BECAUSE SAM IS, LIKE,
THE LITTLE SOUTHERN BELLE,
AND, YOU KNOW,
SHE'S FROM ALABAMA.
>> SO THEN JUST TWIST
YOUR BODIES BOTH OUT TO ME.
>> OKAY.
>> IT WAS TOUGH.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE A BOYFRIEND,
AND IT WAS HARD
TO HAVE TO ACT LIKE
I WAS IN LOVE WITH ANOTHER GIRL.
>> I LIKE THE SMILING.
WHY DON'T YOU GUYS
HAVE A HAPPY MOMENT?
>> OKAY.
>> LESBIANS AREN'T SERIOUS
ALL THE TIME.
>> I GO TO DARTMOUTH,
SO I DEFINITELY THINK PLAYING,
YOU KNOW, COLLEGE BASKETBALL
KINDA HELPED WITH THE--
WITH THE LESBIAN SCENE.
(laughs)
>> (British accent)
I'VE COME TO THE WEDDING.
>> I'M GONNA BE YOUR WEDDING
PHOTOGRAPHER,SWEETHEART.
>> OH, THAT'S NICE, TOO.
I AGREE.
>> ARE YOU TELLING ME
TO KISS YOUR HAND?
>> NO, YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
>> WHERE YOU FROM?
>> (normal voice) I'M FROM
HOUSTON.
>> FROM HOUSTON?
>> YES.
(laughter)
>> THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT BAD,
ACTUALLY.
>> YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
THE EPITOME
OF THE PERFECT MARRIAGE.
FELICIA DEFINITELY
NEEDS TO STEP IT UP.
SHE COULD'VE REALLY WORKED IT,
AND SHE DIDN'T PLAY OFF
OF THE MANNEQUIN TOO WELL.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> MY PHOTO SHOOT TODAY,
I'M GONNA BE A VEGAN.
THAT MEANS THAT
THE ONLY THING I EAT IS, LIKE,
TOMATOES, CARROTS, LETTUCE.
YOU KNOW,
ANYTHING THAT'S BASICALLY
IS GROWING UP OUT OF THE EARTH,
LIKE JALAPEÑO PEPPERS
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> I THINK YOU'D BE
A BIT MORE EMOTIVE
ABOUT THE WHOLE THING.
ONE LEG UP AND ONE LEG DOWN.
AND REST YOUR ARM FROM UP THERE.
I THINK DIONNE COULD'VE HAD
MORE FUN WITH IT.
SHE COULD'VE TAKEN IT
JUST A LITTLE BIT FURTHER.
YOU'D TAKE IT TO ONE LEVEL,
BUT YOU REALLY WANNA TAKE
IT TO THE TOP LEVEL.
>> DID YOU SEE YOUR LITTLE TABLE
OVER THERE?
>> OH, MY GOODNESS, MEAT GALORE.
>> MEAT GALORE.
>> THE SET WAS CRAZY.
THERE WAS MEAT ALL OVER THE
TABLE.
IT WAS WILD.
>> SWEETIE, DON'T FORGET
PRETTY IN THE EYES.
>> I WOULD RATHER SEE YOU
KINDA TEARING APART A CHICKEN.
IT WOULD FEEL MORE EDITORIAL
THAN PICKING UP THE HAMBURGER.
I THINK THESE GIRLS
ARE ALL VERY FLAT
ACROSS THE BOARD TODAY.
BUT I KNOW THIS IS
THE FIRST SHOOT,
AND THE GIRLS REALLY PUT
THEIR BEST FOOT FORWARD.
THEY TRIED HARD.
>> GREAT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> SO DID YOU HAVE FUN TODAY?
>> YES!
>> SOME OF YOU KINDA GAVE ME
A WEAK SHOT,
AND I WASN'T SO HAPPY.
AND I KNOW IT'S TOUGH.
IT'S THE BEGINNING OF THIS
COMPETITION,
BUT WE REALLY NEED
TO STEP IT UP.
THERE'S A SURPRISE DOWNSTAIRS
WAITING FOR YOU GUYS.
>> (cheering)
>> WELL, GO CHECK IT OUT.
YOU GOT A SURPRISE.
YOU GOTTA GO.
>> WE'RE WALKING DOWN
THE STAIRS...
(bell dings)
(horn honks)
>> THERE'S, LIKE, A HUGE LIMO.
I'M LIKE, OH, MY GOD!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> WHOO!
>> SOMEBODY PIMPED IT
OUT OR SOMETHING.
LIKE, IT HAD PILLOWS AND, LIKE,
PICTURES ON THE MIRRORS.
IT HAD TYRA'S FACE.
>> AAH!
>> (laughs)
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> SARAH--SHE STARTS SCREAMING,
"WE GOT TYRA MAIL!
WE GOT TYRA MAIL!"
>> READ IT!
>> "THE PAST IS NEW AGAIN.
WELCOME TO THE FASHION
HOUSE OF HISTORY.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> (cheering)
>> WE'RE GOING,
"WE'RE GOING TO THE HOUSE!
WE GET TO GO SEE THE HOUSE!"
>> (singsongy) WE'RE GOING
TO THE HOUSE.
WE'RE GOING TO THE HOUSE.
>> WHAT, WHAT?
♪♪♪
>> SO THE LIMO DROPS US OFF
AT THE HOUSE,
AND WE WALK UP
TO THIS BEAUTIFUL, AMAZING,
HUGE MANSION.
>> (cheering)
>> WE OPENED THE DOORS,
AND IT'S LIKE FREAKIN' HEAVEN.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> AAH!
>> THE THEME OF THE HOUSE
IS THE PREVIOUS GIRLS
FROM "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
THERE'S EVA'S PICTURES...
EVA'S QUOTES,
DANIELLE'S PICTURES...
>> BEAUTIFUL!
>> THEN THERE'S NAIMA'S,
YOANNA'S,
EVERYBODY THAT I LOOKED UP TO,
YOU KNOW?
>> WE ALL WENT
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS,
'CAUSE THE THING WAS,
WE JUST WANTED TO GET A BED.
THIS IS MY ROOM! WHOO!
(glass shatters)
>> AAH!
>> (screaming)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> THERE'S A POOL!
>> WHOO!
>> THERE'S A HUGE RUNWAY
WITH TYRA'S FACE ON THE BACK.
>> (screaming)
AHH!!
THERE YOU GO.
>> OH, I LOVE IT.
I'M A RUNWAY FIEND.
>> LET'S GO WHUP
SOME MODEL BUTT.
>> YOU KNOW,
JAEL'S KIND OF CRAZY.
SHE KEEPS ME FUN,
BECAUSE I THINK THAT
I MAY TAKE THIS
TOO SERIOUSLY AT TIMES.
>> PLEASE DON'T EVER
LEAVE ME ALONE AGAIN!
I THINK RENEE IS WONDERFUL.
I REALLY LOVE THE DIFFERENCES
IN PEOPLE,
AND RENEE IS KIND OF LIKE
AN OPPOSITE OF ME.
MWAH.
>> ARE YOU CRYING, GIRL?
>> YES, I'M SORRY.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
WHEN YOU LOOK OUT
OVER THOSE HILLS,
IT'S A SURREAL FEELING.
I MADE IT THIS FAR,
AND THIS IS WHERE I WANNA STAY.
(sniffles)
♪♪♪
>> I DO.
>> YOU OWN CALIFORNIA.
YOU ARE L.A.
YOU OWN L.A.!
THESE GIRLS ARE, LIKE, THE BOMB,
BUT I FEEL LIKE ALL THE GIRLS
ARE MY COMPETITION
'CAUSE THEY ALL HAVE, LIKE,
THEIR OWN UNIQUE BEAUTIFULNESS.
CAN I DO IT WITH SOMEBODY?
I WANNA DO IT
WITH A WHITE PERSON, THOUGH...
>> I WANNA SEE.
>> 'CAUSE IT'S GONNA LOOK LIKE
CHOCOLATE AND VANILLA.
COME ON.
>> I THINK KATHLEEN IS, LIKE,
THE MOST OUTSPOKEN IN THE HOUSE.
SHE'S FROM NEW YORK.
SHE KNOWS WHAT TO SAY
AND WHEN TO SAY IT.
>> I LOOK SO MAD.
>> MY GOAL IS TO SHOOT "VOGUE"
BY THE TIME I'M 25.
>> SHOOT "VOGUE"
OR BE IN "VOGUE"?
>> SHOOT "VOGUE."
I'D LOVE TO GO INTO ACTING.
I'D LOVE TO ACT, AND, LIKE,
THEY'VE ALWAYS SAID THAT
I'VE DONE REALLY WELL, LIKE...
>> OH, YOU'VE BEEN IN MOVIES?
>> YEAH. I'VE DONE EVERYTHING.
>> SARAH MAY BE INSECURE.
SHE'S KIND OF FULL OF HERSELF,
SHE'S A PHOTOGRAPHER,
AND SHE BRAGS A LOT.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE
IT'S HARD FOR YOU TO FOCUS
'CAUSE YOU CAN'T FOCUS, LIKE,
100% OF YOUR ATTENTION
ON MODELING IF YOU HAVE
ALL THESE OTHER THINGS?
>> NO, LIKE,
I--ONE THING THAT I DO
IS NO MATTER WHAT I DO,
I DO IT 100%.
>> IT'S NOTHING AGAINST YOU,
BUT THERE IS, LIKE,
TONS OF OTHER GIRLS
WHO WOULD DIE TO BE HERE
FOR MODELING.
>> HOW DARE YOU TELL ME
WHAT I WANNA BE HERE FOR.
I'M HERE TO MODEL.
I AM NOT HERE TO GET RIDICULED.
YEAH, AND I AM HERE TO MODEL.
>> YOU--NO, NO, NO,
AND I KNOW THAT.
DON'T--DON'T GET DEFENSIVE.
>> YEAH, I KNOW,
AND, LIKE, I AM.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> (screaming)
>> "ONE WOMAN'S TRASH
IS ANOTHER WOMAN'S TREASURE.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> (cheering)
>> WAIT, WHAT DO WOMEN
THROW AWAY?
LIPSTICK AND STUFF, RIGHT?
I KNOW, LIKE,
I'M GONNA HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
WITH, LIKE, CRAP.
NOT CRAP LITERALLY,
BUT, LIKE, SOMETHING
THAT SOMEONE THREW AWAY.
>> TREASURE.
>> OUR CHARIOTS AWAIT.
>> THE TYRA MAIL READ,
"ONE WOMAN'S TRASH
IS ANOTHER WOMAN'S TREASURE."
AND THEN WE GET INTO GOODWILL.
>> WE WALK IN AND WE SEE MISS J.
>> WELCOME.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GUYS KNOW
WHO THIS PERSON IS.
HE IS THE STYLIST TO THE STARS.
THIS IS PHILLIP BLOCH.
>> HI!
>> HELLO, PHILLIP.
>> THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
>> AND I'M EXTREMELY EXCITED
BECAUSE I SEE HIM ON TV
DOING DIFFERENT THINGS
FOR THE STARS,
AND HE'S JUST AMAZING.
>> YOU MAY SAY,
"OH, WHY ARE WE STANDING HERE IN
GOODWILL SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA?"
"WHY" IS BECAUSE
GOODWILL OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IS NOT ONLY
A GREAT PLACE TO SHOP,
BUT IT DOES WONDERFUL WORK
FOR THE COMMUNITY.
EVERY 57 SECONDS
OF EVERY BUSINESS DAY,
THEY PLACE SOMEONE
WHO IS VOCATIONALLY CHALLENGED
IN A NEW JOB.
SO, LADIES, YOUR CHALLENGE TODAY
IS TO WORK THE STORE--
RUMMAGE THROUGH THE RACKS
AND FIND THE BEST LOOK FOR YOU.
>> AND I'LL BE WATCHING
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
AS YOU CREATE
YOUR OWN PERSONAL STYLE.
>> YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
THREE MINUTES.
>> (gasps)
>> I'M REALLY NERVOUS ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE I'M LIKE, HOW AM I GONNA
SHOP THIS WHOLE STORE
IN THREE MINUTES?
I NEED TIME TO THINK.
>> ARE YOU READY?
>> YES!
>> ONE...
TWO...
THREE.
GO!
>> AAH! GO! GO! GO!
>> WE ALMOST GOT RUN OVER.
>> I'M VERY FAMILIAR
WITH SHOPPING IN THRIFT STORES.
LIKE, I REALLY LOVE
WEARING CLOTHES
THAT TELL A STORY.
>> I SEE A LOT OF EMPTY HANDS.
DON'T YOU, MISS J.?
>> I DON'T GO THRIFT
STORE SHOPPING.
THERE'S NOT THAT MANY
GOOD THRIFT STORES ON MAUI.
>> ONE MINUTE!
>> TO ME, IT WAS, LIKE,
NO PROBLEM.
IT'S A THRIFT SHOP, YOU KNOW.
I ROCK IN THRIFT SHOPS.
>> THREE...
TWO...
ONE.
STOP.
SO, GIRLS, THIS WAS NOT JUST
A CHALLENGE ON STYLE.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY DRESSED BECAUSE
OUTSIDE THOSE DOORS...
YOU'LL BE WALKING THE RUNWAY
TO DO A CHARITY FASHION SHOW.
>> (cheering)
>> I'M REALLY, REALLY SCARED.
I'M REALLY EXCITED.
I'M LIKE, OH, MY GOSH,
WE'RE GONNA BE
WALKING OUT ON THE RUNWAY
IN FRONT OF AN AUDIENCE.
>> THERE WILL BE AN AUCTION
AFTERWARDS.
THE MODEL WHOSE OUTFIT
GETS THE HIGHEST BID
WILL BE THE WINNER,
AND THEN ALL THE PROCEEDS
FROM THE AUCTION
WILL GO TO GOODWILL
IN THE NAME OF THE WINNER.
>> AND REMEMBER, GIRLS,
IT'S THE CROWD WHO DECIDES,
SO GO OUT THERE
AND STRUT YOUR STUFF.
SO GIRLS ARE YOU READY?
>> YEAH!
♪♪♪
>> NATASHA...
GO.
>> (cheering)
>> OH!
STRIPES ARE BACK,
AND IT'S ALL ABOUT
LAYERING THE TANK TOP.
AND HERE, OUR LOVELY LADIES
HAVE CHOSEN ALL THEIR CLOTHES
FROM THE GOODWILL.
ALL RIGHT!
>> (cheering)
>> ALL I'VE SEEN WAS KATHLEEN,
SHE WAS JUST
STRAIGHT UP BROOKLYN HOOCHIE
WITH A TWIST,
AND THE TWIST IS THAT SHE HAS
A GREAT PERSONALITY.
>> NOTICE HOW THE SHOES
MATCH THE HAIR.
>> DEEP DOWN INSIDE,
I FELT LIKE I ROCKED
ON THAT RUNWAY.
THE CROWD WAS LOVING ME.
>> VERY AVANT-GARDE.
OUR NEXT MODEL
IS GIVING BOHO CHIC.
>> RENEE'S OUTFIT--
I THINK IT WORKED.
I MEAN, IT IS ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL STYLE.
AND, I MEAN, WHO KNOWS?
SHE COULD BE A TRENDSETTER.
>> AND WE LOVE
THE HIPPIE, BOHEMIAN SKIRT.
>> (cheering)
>> IT'S THE NEW LENGTH IN PANTS.
NO, THERE'S NO FLOOD.
IT'S JUST THE NEW LENGTH.
AND HERE WE'VE GOT
A LITTLE BIT OF A TOMBOY LOOK.
>> BRITTANY--WITH EVERYTHING
HERE IN THE GOODWILL,
IS THAT ALL YOU CAME UP WITH?
HOPEFULLY,
SHE'LL LEARN SOMETHING
FROM THIS.
>> WHOO!
>> ALL RIGHT!
YOU LIKE THAT ONE, HUH?
THE MODEL OR THE CLOTHES?
MM-HMM!
AND THAT COAT
WILL KEEP YOU WARM.
NOTICE THE SHORT SHORTS
AND THE LIGHT PINK
THROWN ON WITH THE SILVER SHOES.
YOU ARE READY TO GO DANCING.
LET'S HAVE SOME APPLAUSE
FOR OUR NEXT MODEL
READY TO COME OUT HERE
AND STRUT HER STUFF.
AND I LOVE THIS LITTLE CARDIGAN,
VERY DOLCE & GABBANA.
NOW THIS IS CREATIVITY.
JUST THROW ON THAT COAT,
AND YOU'RE READY TO GO.
>> I'VE WALKED FASHION
SHOWS BEFORE,
SO IT'S, LIKE,
I'M NOT SCARED OF THE RUNWAY.
I THINK I DID A VERY GOOD WALK.
>> MEN'S TAILORING
IS VERY HOT THIS SEASON.
AND NOTICE SHE PUNCTUATED
WITH THE RED
UNDERNEATH THE HOUNDSTOOTH.
(growls)
THE CALL OF THE WILD.
ANIMAL PRINTS--
VERY BIG ON THE RUNWAYS
THIS SEASON.
>> WHOO!
>> AND NEXT WE HAVE
A SPLASH OF COLOR--
PINK, PURPLE, YELLOW.
>> THAT LOOKS ALL SECONDHAND.
YOU CAN BUY SECONDHAND
AND MAKE IT WORK,
AND JAEL MADE IT WORK.
>> AND GIRLFRIEND
IS WORKING THAT FIGURE.
SHE IS WALKING FOR THE RENT.
RIGHT, BABY?
>> WALKING OUT IN FRONT OF,
LIKE, A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
THAT YOU DON'T KNOW--
IT EMPOWERED ME.
IT MADE ME FEEL
VERY, VERY BEAUTIFUL.
>> OW!
>> (cheering)
>> DON'T HURT NOBODY!
THERE YOU GO.
WE ARE READY
FOR A DAY AT THE BEACH,
RIGHT DOWN TO THE HAT, THE BAG.
IT IS THE FINAL VISAGE.
LET'S GIVE THESE GIRLS
A GREAT ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
MAKE THOSE DONATIONS
TO THE GOODWILL
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
♪♪♪
>> HMM, HMM, HMM.
WE SAW QUITE A BIT OF STYLING
AND SOME FAUX PAS.
BUT ENOUGH SAID.
WE RAISED... HOW MUCH?
>> $286.50,
WHICH IS GREAT.
>> THE WINNER WHOSE OUTFIT
GOT THE HIGHEST BID
IS GOING TO SIGN THIS CHECK.
>> (cheering)
>> AND I HAVE THE
MARKER IN HAND.
>> OH, MAN!
>> JAEL!
>> (cheering)
>> I FELT LIKE I DID MY BEST
AND I THINK I DESERVED
TO BE RECOGNIZED.
>> GIRL, HAVE YOU EVER
SIGNED A CHECK, BABY?
>> (laughs) CONGRATULATIONS.
>> (cheering)
>> THE ONLY REASON
THAT JAEL WON WAS 'CAUSE
SHE'S A THRIFT SHOPPER.
SO IT'S, LIKE, YOU KNOW, LET'S--
IT'S NOT EVEN LIKE
IT WAS A "MODELING" THING.
IT'S NOT FAIR.
IT'S NOT FAIR AT ALL.
>> I'M SO EXCITED THAT I WON.
HONESTLY, LIKE,
I DON'T REALLY KNOW
HOW TO PORTRAY THAT
TO THE OTHER GIRLS,
BECAUSE THIS IS A COMPETITION,
AND I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO BE COMPETITIVE.
>> YOU DID GOOD.
>> YOU GUYS STILL LOVE ME?
>> OF COURSE!
>> OKAY, GOOD.
I'M SEEING THINGS.
I'M TOTALLY SEEING THINGS.
YOU'RE LIKE, "THAT BITCH?"
>> I KNOW THAT JAEL
IS, YOU KNOW,
ALL ABOUT BEING BEST FRIENDS
WITH EVERYBODY, BUT
I DON'T FEEL LIKE
IT'S A GOOD THING TO, LIKE,
HOLD IT BACK AND TRY AND PLAY
THE NICE PERSON, YOU KNOW,
ALL THE TIME.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT--THAT'S--THAT'S NOT REAL.
>> JAEL, I WAS STARTING
TO GET A LITTLE BIT UPSET
WITH YOU.
YOU ACT LIKE EVERYTHING'S OKAY
ALL THE TIME.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU GET
ANNOYED WITH THESE GIRLS.
I'VE SEEN YOU.
>> YEAH, BUT YOU'RE NOT
ACCEPTING THE FACT
THAT I AM, LIKE, GENUINELY...
EXPRESSING MY FEELINGS
HONESTLY, OKAY?
I'M NOT TRYING TO, LIKE,
FORCE HAPPINESS ON EVERYONE.
I'M NOT LIKE THAT.
DON'T IMPRESS YOUR
PERSONAL FEELINGS ON ME.
>> OKAY, JUST--YOU--YOU WANT ME
NOT TO STATE MY OPINIONS?
>> I THINK MY RELATIONSHIP
WITH RENEE KIND OF
WEARS ME OUT EMOTIONALLY.
YOU'RE AWAY FROM YOUR CHILD
AND YOUR HUSBAND, OKAY?
LIKE, I GOT NOTHING TO LOSE
WHILE I'M HERE RIGHT NOW.
IT'S TOTALLY DIFFERENT,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I'M NOT GOING THROUGH
ANYTHING LIKE THAT RIGHT NOW IN
MY LIFE LIKE YOU ARE.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "TOMORROW YOU WILL HAVE
YOUR FIRST MEETING
WITH THE JUDGES."
>> WHOO!
>> "ONLY 12 OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> YEAH!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
>> OH!
>> EVERYBODY NERVOUS?
>> I'M EXCITED. I'M GLAD.
>> I'M EXCITED.
>> I AM, TOO.
>> YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN,
SO I'M, LIKE,
SO NERVOUS FOR PANEL.
I THINK I DID GOOD
AT THE GOODWILL,
BUT NOW I FEEL LIKE
THE FIRST PERSON WHO GOES HOME,
LIKE, THEY DIDN'T EVEN
HAVE A CHANCE.
>> NO, DON'T FEEL THAT WAY.
>> I JUST WANT THEM TO KNOW
THAT.
LIKE, YOU KNOW,
I REALLY THINK I DID GOOD.
LIKE, I REALLY, LIKE, WANT THIS.
LIKE, THAT'S WHY I DID SO GOOD.
>> I KNOW.
THAT'S WHY YOU KEEP THAT HUNGER,
KEEP THAT DRIVE.
>> YOU HAVE TO REALIZE,
YOU'RE NOT THE JUDGE OF YOU NOW.
LIKE, YOU HAVE OTHER PEOPLE
JUDGING YOU.
YOU COULD THINK THAT
YOU'RE SO HOT,
BUT DOES PANEL THINK
YOU'RE HOT, SWEETIE?
GIVE ME A HUG, JASLENE.
>> AW! IT'S OKAY.
THAT'S HOW YOU FEEL.
YOU WANNA BE A CRYBABY,
CRY, GIRL.
I CRIED A MILLION TIMES
THAT NIGHT.
>> I'M READY FOR ELIMINATIONS,
READY FOR ALL THOSE GIRLS
IN THERE TO GO HOME,
AND I'M ONE STEP CLOSER.
THAT'S ALL I CARE ABOUT.
I KNOW I'M NOT GOING HOME.
>> AND MY MENTALITY IN THIS IS,
THEY CAN WIN ALL
THE LITTLE BATTLES.
I'M GONNA WIN THIS WAR.
♪♪♪
>> WELL, HELLO, MISS LADIES.
>> HI, TYRA!
>> WELCOME TO
THE VERY FIRST JUDGING.
NEVER THOUGHT
YOU'D BE STANDING THERE, RIGHT?
YOU SEE GIRLS EVERY SEASON
ON "TOP MODEL"--
"WHY SHE SO NERVOUS? LOOK, IF I
WAS THERE, I'D BE FINE."
BUT I KNOW THE PITS
ARE SWEATING, AREN'T THEY?
>> (laughing)
>> YES, THERE ARE 13 OF YOU.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, ONE OF YOU
IS GOING TO BE GOING HOME
THIS EVENING.
I'M GONNA TELL YOU
ABOUT THE PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT,
WHICH IS ONE OF THE
TOP MODELING AGENCIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD...
ALSO, A COVER AND SPREAD
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND THE MOST AMAZING PRIZE--
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH... WHAT?
>> COVERGIRL COSMETICS!
THERE YOU GO.
THE FIRST JUDGE
IS NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
AND VERY SEXY MAN,
NIGEL BARKER...
SEXY RUNWAY DIVA COACH
EXTRAORDINAIRE,
MISS J. ALEXANDER...
>> HEY, J.
>> ¿QUé TAL?
>> AND TWIGGLES TWIGLET TWIGGY--
LIVING LEGEND
IN THIS FASHION INDUSTRY.
>> I WISH YOU ALL
GREAT GOOD LUCK.
>> AND I KNOW TWIGGY HAS A LOT
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE HISTORY
PERSONALLY.
>> I CERTAINLY DO.
WHEN I WAS 16 1/2 YEARS OLD,
I GOT A CALL TO COME TO AMERICA,
AND I WAS ON
"SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE
IN A LITTLE RED MINIDRESS,
WITH AN AMERICAN FLAG
AND AN ENGLISH FLAG.
THEY DID ALL RIGHT FOR ME,
SO GOOD LUCK TO YOU ALL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THIS WEEK, YOU HAD
A VERY, VERY CONTROVERSIAL
PHOTO SHOOT.
IT WAS ALL ABOUT MAKING
A STATEMENT.
MAYBE YOU AGREE WITH IT,
MAYBE YOU DON'T.
BUT THE PICTURE
STILL HAS TO BE...
FIERCE.
JAEL, YOU'RE FIRST.
YOU WERE THE CHALLENGE WINNER.
CONGRATULATIONS.
(applause)
(normal voice) HOW DID IT FEEL
WINNING THAT FIRST CHALLENGE?
>> I WAS, LIKE,
KIND OF NERVOUS THAT
IT WOULD CHANGE THINGS
BETWEEN HOW THE OTHER GIRLS
TREATED ME.
>> SO YOU WANNA DULL YOUR SHINE
TO BE LIKED?
>> I GUESS.
>> DO THE BEST YOU CAN
SO PEOPLE CAN LIVE UP
TO BE LIKE YOU.
>> YEAH, I'VE BEEN REALIZING
THAT.
>> ALL RIGHT, JAEL,
WHAT POLITICAL ISSUE WERE YOU?
>> UM, I WAS PRO-LIFE,
BUT I AM DEFINITELY VERY LIBERAL
AND I AM PRO-CHOICE.
>> SO LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT YOUR FACE,
IT'S PRETTY, IT'S ATTRACTIVE...
>> MM-HMM.
>> BUT THAT IS NOT,
"I'M STOPPING WOMEN FROM TAKING
UNBORN BABIES OUT OF THIS ROOM."
>> MM.
>> FASHION IS ABOUT EXTREMES,
AND YOU'RE NOT AN
ACTRESS IN A MOVIE
THAT HAS 120 PAGES OF LINES
TO CONVEY A MESSAGE.
IT'S ONE PHOTO,
IT'S ONE MOMENT.
AND THAT ONE MOMENT YOU HAVE TO
SELL IT.
IF YOU DON'T WANT WOMEN TO WALK
INTO THAT CLINIC,
YOU ARE NOT GOING GO,
YOU ARE GOING TO GO,
STOP! NO!-----AH!
>> I UNDERSTAND.
I DID HAVE A FEVER,
AND I WILL NEVER, EVER LET THAT
AFFECT MY PHOTOGRAPH AGAIN.
>> YOU NEED TO PULL IT TOGETHER.
I HAVE BEEN SICK RIGHT HERE
AND HAD TO NOT JUST LOOK RIGHT
BUT LEAD THIS JUDGING PANEL.
I CAN'T TELL SOMEBODY,
"I HAVE A FEVER, AND I'M GONNA
BE LOW-ENERGY TODAY."
LOW ENERGY ON A PHOTO SHOOT
MEANS LOWER SALES.
>> YEAH, THERE'S NO EXCUSE.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANKS, JAEL.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS... NATASHA.
YOU WERE...
>> PRO-CHOICE.
>> IT'S LIKE A POLAROID.
>> YOU'RE ATTEMPTING
TO BLEND INTO THE BACKGROUND
INSTEAD OF POPPING OUT.
>> YOU HAVE MORE EXPRESSION
ON YOUR FACE NOW,
LISTENING TO US, THAN THERE.
>> THERE'S NO CONNECTION
WITH THE CAMERA.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, NATASHA.
DIONNE.
SO WHAT POLITICAL ISSUE
WERE YOU TO PORTRAY?
>> I WAS A VEGAN.
>> AND WHAT'S YOUR STANCE ON
THAT?
>> PERSONALLY, I LIKE MY MEAT.
>> YOU DO HAVE A VERY STRONG
FACE.
CAN WE HAVE A LOOK AT THE
CLOSE-UP?
>> IT'S A VERY PRETTY PICTURE,
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
IT'S, AGAIN, STRONG ENOUGH
TO PUT OVER THE MESSAGE.
>> I THINK THIS IS A GOOD SHOT,
NOT A GREAT SHOT.
I WOULD HAVE LIKED TO SEE
A LITTLE BIT MORE NECK...
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND I FEEL LIKE YOUR JAW
LOOKS A LITTLE TOO BIG,
AND YOU DON'T HAVE THAT JAW.
>> OKAY.
>> CASSANDRA.
YOU'RE PRO-MEAT,
SO WE HAVE TO SEE
IF YOU ARE REALLY EVOKING
WHAT IS INSIDE
OF YOUR HEART AND YOUR STOMACH.
>> I GET--I GET THE MESSAGE.
SHE LOVES MEAT. IT'S THERE.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU'RE GIVING EMOTION LIKE,
"AHH, I LIKE THE MEAT."
BUT JUST "I LIKE THE MEAT,"
BUT--BUT KEEP IT--KEEP IT NICE,
KEEP IT PRETTY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AND, RENEE, YOU WERE TO BE
WHAT?
>> ANTI-GUN.
>> THAT'S LIKE,
"MAKE LOVE, NOT WAR."
>> YOU SLIGHTLY DISAPPOINTED ME.
I GOT A GREAT SHOT OUT OF YOU,
BUT THEY ALL LOOKED LIKE THIS.
>> YOU LOOK SCARED.
YOU LOOK SCARED IN FRONT OF US
AND IN THE PHOTO, I THINK.
>> YEAH.
>> I HAD THIS SAME ENERGY ON
SET,
THIS VERY TIMID AND
KIND OF NERVOUS.
>> (voice breaks) UM, ONE THING
THAT I'M ALWAYS THINKING ABOUT
IS MY SON AND THAT
I'M DOING THIS
ALL FOR HIM.
AND I KNOW THAT I CAN DO BETTER.
I KNOW THAT I CAN DO BETTER
THAN THAT.
>> THANK YOU, RENEE.
UP NEXT IS DIANA.
WHAT POLITICAL ISSUE WERE YOU?
>> I WAS PRO-GUN.
>> MM,
SHE HAS SLIGHTLY DEAD EYES.
>> THERE'S NO...
NOTHING THERE IN HER EYE
THAT COULD REALLY POP.
THE FACE IS ALMOST THERE.
IT'S--IT'S ALMOST THERE
A LITTLE BIT AROUND THE MOUTH.
>> YEAH, YOU'RE A LITTLE WEAK
IN THE EYES.
YOU LOST THE CONCEPT
WHEN IT GOT TO THIS PART.
>> MM.
>> ON THE SORT OF POSITIVE SIDE,
I ENJOYED SHOOTING YOU.
YOU WENT FOR IT.
BUT WE THOUGHT THIS WAS
QUITE GOOD, THE FACT THAT
SHE COULD DO A JUMPING SHOT
AND MOVE.
>> ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS
KATHLEEN.
KATHLEEN GOT SOME HAIR GOING ON
TODAY.
>> HI GUYS.
>> SO, KATHLEEN,
YOU HAD TO DO A POLITICAL ISSUE.
YOURS WAS?
>> ANTI-FUR.
>> ANTI-FUR?
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT FUR?
>> I BELIEVE THAT
IF THE ANIMAL'S ALIVE,
YOU SHOULDN'T KILL IT
TO MAKE A FUR COAT OR ANYTHING.
BUT IF IT'S ALREADY DEAD,
THEN YOU COULD TAKE
THE SKIN OFF...
(record needle scratches)
AND JUST MAKE A COAT.
>> HOW WOULD IT ALREADY BE DEAD?
LIKE...
>> LET'S SAY YOU KNOW 'CAUSE
ANIMALS
FIGHT EACH OTHER
IN THE JUNGLE, RIGHT?
IN THE WOODS.
>> YOU HAVE TO GO FIND-- FIND
THE ANIMAL?
>> (laughs) BUT THAT'S NOT--
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT'S NOT
HOW THEY GET FUR COATS.
>> ANIMALS DIE, LIKE, PEOPLE
DIE NATURALLY SOMETIMES, RIGHT?
>> MM-HMM.
>> BUT THAT'S NOT THE ONES
THEY USE FOR FUR COATS,
I'M AFRAID.
>> OH.
>> I MEAN, I'M VERY, VERY
ANTI-FUR.
>> SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> SO, KATHLEEN,
YOU HAD ONE OF THE BEST SETS.
IT WAS AN EASY ONE TO FIT IN TO.
BUT I THINK THAT
YOU DIDN'T COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
THE CONCEPT.
>> I KNOW, RIGHT? I DIDN'T.
>> (laughs)
>> IF YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
SOMETHING, YOU HAVE TO ASK.
SO IF YOU WOULD'VE JUST SAID,
"MR. JAY, EXPLAIN TO ME,
LIKE, ANTI-FUR.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
HOW DO THOSE PEOPLE ACT?"
SOME ANTI-FUR PEOPLE
ARE VERY AGGRESSIVE,
AND RIGHT NOW
YOU JUST LOOK LIKE...
(Brooklyn accent) I DON'T KNOW.
>> I KNOW, AND I FEEL LIKE
HE EXPLAINED IT TO ME SO MUCH,
HIM AND NIGEL.
AND I'M LIKE, I DON'T--
I DON'T WANNA SEEM SLOW,
LIKE I WASN'T CATCHING ON.
>> (high-pitched voice) WELL...
>> I AM NOT SLOW!
>> (normal voice) I MEAN,
THERE'S NO EXPRESSION
THAT YOU'RE ANGRY HERE AT ALL
IN THIS PICTURE.
I'M ANGRY THAT YOU
DIDN'T GET IT.
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU,
KATHLEEN.
BRITTANY, WHAT POLITICAL ISSUE
DID YOU HAVE TO DO?
>> I WAS PRO-FUR.
>> OH, I THINK
IT'S A WONDERFUL PHOTOGRAPH.
I THINK YOU'VE GOT THE MOOD.
>> I COULD'VE USED AN EXTRA...
>> ME, TOO.
IT'S, LIKE, YOUR LITTLE--
YOU'RE A LITTLE SETTLED...
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
>> YOU WOULD'VE SAID...
>> IT'S LIKE A BIRD,
VERY STRIKING.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WHITNEY AND SAMANTHA.
YOUR POLITICAL ISSUE WAS...
>> GAY MARRIAGE.
>> GAY AND LESBIAN MARRIAGE.
(laughter)
>> NO, I'VE BEEN EXPOSED.
I'VE DEFINITELY BEEN EXPOSED.
>> AND WHAT ABOUT YOU, SAMANTHA?
>> I DON'T THINK ANYONE
CAN SIT THERE AND SAY
THAT YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO MARRY THE PERSON
YOU'RE IN LOVE WITH,
SO I'M ABSOLUTELY FINE WITH IT.
>> WELL, BOTH YOU GIRLS
DID A GREAT JOB.
BUT WHAT YOU DIDN'T DO
IS YOU DIDN'T LISTEN TO ME
OR JAY WHEN WE SAID,
"TWIST YOUR BODIES TO US MORE."
ESPECIALLY YOU, WHITNEY.
>> EVEN THOUGH YOU HAVE ON
A BULKY SUIT,
IF YOU CAN WORK YOUR BODY
A CERTAIN WAY,
YOU'RE ABLE TO SEE IT
UNDERNEATH CLOTHES.
>> CAN WE SEE A CLOSE-UP
OF SAMANTHA?
YOU'VE GOT
THE MOST BEAUTIFUL NECK.
SAMANTHA TOOK THIS ENTIRE PHOTO.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FELICIA.
YOU HAD TO DO WHAT?
>> STRAIGHT MARRIAGE.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT THAT ISSUE?
>> I LOVE IT. I LOVE MEN.
>> I ACTUALLY
QUITE LIKE THIS SHOT.
IT'S VERY KIND OF TWEE
AND KIND OF KITSCH, AND I THINK
YOU--YOU'VE PULLED IT OFF.
>> YOU DID A GOOD JOB.
IT LOOKS LIKE "BRIDAL MAGAZINE."
>> IT'S WONDERFUL.
>> YES, LIKE LITTLE--
FIGURINES ON TOP OF A CAKE.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU,
FELICIA.
JASLENE.
YOUR POLITICAL ISSUE WAS?
>> THE DEATH PENALTY.
>> YOU'RE READY.
>> THAT'S A STRONG PHOTOGRAPH.
>> NOW LET'S HAVE A CLOSE-UP
OF YOUR EYES.
>> OH!
>> OH, YES.
WELL, THE CAMERA LOVES YOU.
>> IT'S SOMETHING EXTRA SPECIAL.
>> I DIDN'T PUT
THOSE TWO TOGETHER,
AND YOU'VE GOT SOMETHING.
>> WHERE'S JASLENE THE
PERSONALITY?
WHERE IS SHE?
>> SHE'S HERE.
>> WE WANNA SEE HER!
>> WELL, IF YOU GUYS WANT ME
TO STOMP DOWN 180 STEPS,
I WILL STOMP DOWN 180 STEPS,
AND BEST BELIEVE THAT LAST STEP
WILL BE JUST AS FIERCE
AS THE FIRST ONE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT, WELL,
WALK BACK TO YOUR SPACE DOING
THAT.
>> GO, GIRL!
>> I JUST WANNA SEE THAT
PERSONALITY
THAT GOT YOU HERE.
JUST 'CAUSE YOU GOT THE JOB
DOESN'T MEAN
YOU'RE GONNA KEEP THE JOB.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST IS SARAH.
SO WHAT POLITICAL ISSUE
DID YOU DO?
>> I HAD LIFE IN PRISON.
>> NO.
>> AND I DON'T THINK JAY NOR I
FELT IT EITHER.
YOU DIDN'T DO MUCH
WITH YOUR FACE.
YOUR FACE WAS THE SAME IN EVERY
SHOT.
>> THERE ARE TWO STRONG CHOICES
YOU COULD'VE MADE.
THERE TENDS TO BE
TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF CONVICTS.
THERE'S THE ONE THAT JUST
FEELS LIKE, "OH, MY GOD.
I'M JUST GONNA DIE HERE
AND I FEEL SO SAD."
THEN THERE'S THE ONE
THAT EVERYBODY IS SCARED OF
IN THE JAIL, BECAUSE THEY HAVE
NOTHING TO LOSE,
SO THEY'RE CRAZY!
"I DON'T CARE! I'LL KILL YOU!
WHAT YOU GONNA GIVE ME, LIFE?
WHAT? WHAT ELSE CAN YOU GIVE ME?
I'M IN HERE."
SO THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT ONES,
AND YOU--YOU DIDN'T DO EITHER.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
13 OF YOU HAVE COME FROM
VERY FAR PLACES TO BE HERE,
AND, UNFORTUNATELY, ONE OF YOU
IS GOING TO HAVE TO GO HOME.
AND WHEN YOU COME BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHO THAT IS.
>> SO NOW IT'S TIME TO DECIDE
WHICH ONE OF THESE GIRLS
IS GOING HOME.
LET'S START WITH RENEE.
>> SHE HAS NO PHOTOGRAPHIC
SAVVY YET,
BUT HOPEFULLY SHE'LL LEARN.
>> THE THING THAT I DON'T LIKE
ABOUT RENEE IS THAT I FEEL
MAY CRACK UNDER PRESSURE.
>> YEAH.
>> RENEE LOOKS
ABSOLUTELY TERRIFIED IN THIS
PHOTO,
AND THAT MAKES ME SCARED.
JASLENE.
>> JASLENE...
>> JASLENE.
>> (imitates Jaslene)
SHE'S FIERCE.
>> (laughs)
>> FELICIA.
>> BEAUTIFUL BONE STRUCTURE.
I MEAN, THIS IS RARE TO FIND
SOMEONE AS BEAUTIFUL AS THIS.
>> FELICIA KEEPS ON SAYING
THAT SHE LOOKS LIKE ME,
BUT IN THIS PHOTO, I THINK
SHE LOOKS LIKE NOéMIE LENOIR.
SAMANTHA.
>> I LOVE HER NECK,
I LOVE HER JAW,
I LOVE... I LOVE EVERYTHING.
I THINK, YOU KNOW...
>> SAMANTHA'S DEFINITELY GOT
THE FACE, BUT THE PERSONALITY?
NOT SURE YET.
WHITNEY.
>> I LOVED HER PERSONALITY.
UNFORTUNATELY,
SHE DOES DISAPPEAR
IN THE PHOTOGRAPH.
>> BRITTANY.
>> I LOVE BRITTANY'S PHOTO,
UH, MINUS A FEW LITTLE KINKS.
BUT OTHER THAN THAT,
I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
>> KATHLEEN--
I DO WORRY ABOUT KATHLEEN.
YOU--YOU KIND OF WANT
TO TAKE KATHLEEN HOME
AND LOOK AFTER HER.
>> I DON'T.
>> (laughs)
>> I JUST WORRY
WHETHER SHE CAN UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GOING ON AROUND HER.
>> (imitates Kathleen)
I DON'T KNOW.
>> (groans)
>> SHE'S, UM, SHE'S RATHER
CLUELESS,
I'M AFRAID.
>> CASSANDRA.
>> I THINK THIS IS
QUITE A POWERFUL PHOTOGRAPH.
>> BUT CASSANDRA--
I DON'T THINK SHE'S GOT
REALLY THE MODEL LOOKS
THAT I'M REALLY LOOKING FOR
RIGHT NOW.
>> DIONNE.
>> IN THIS PICTURE,
YOU DON'T SEE THE 1B OR THE 30.
THERE.
>> OH, NO, YOU DO SEE 1B/30...
1B AT THE TOP,
30 RIGHT THERE AT THE BOTTOM.
SARAH.
>> I HAD HIGH HOPES FOR SARAH
WHEN SHE FIRST STEPPED ONTO SET.
BUT I'M AFRAID SHE--
SHE REALLY DIDN'T DELIVER.
>> SHE'S GOT A VERY LONG
MIDDLE SECTION OF HER BODY.
I FIND IT
QUITE STRANGE TO LOOK AT.
>> DIANA IS
PERFECTLY PROPORTIONED...
>> MM.
>> BUT SHE DOESN'T DELIVER
IN THE FACE.
I'M AFRAID SHE'S A LITTLE
DEADPAN.
>> NATASHA.
>> GIRL IS RELYING ON PRETTY,
AND RELYING ON PRETTY, SHE JUST
LOOKS LIKE PART OF THE BUILDING.
>> JAEL.
>> SHE'S TALL,
AND I LOVE TALL GIRLS.
AND SHE ALSO LOOKS VERY FOREIGN.
SHE'S VERY, VERY FOREIGN.
>> SHE LOOKS LIKE AN EXOTIC
BLONDE,
WHICH YOU DON'T GET VERY OFTEN.
>> YOU KNOW WHY?
>> SHE'S NOT BLONDE.
>> SHE'S HALF BLACK.
>> SHE'S NOT.
>> YES!
>> GOODNESS.
>> SHE'S PASSING FOR WHITE,
CHILD.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
SHE JUST DID NOT DELIVER
ON THE DAY OF THE SHOOT.
>> I WAS VERY CONFUSED OF HER
NOT WANTING TO WIN A CHALLENGE
BECAUSE SHE THINKS THAT
THAT'S GONNA MAKE PEOPLE LIKE
HER... FAILING.
>> EVERYONE LIKES A LOSER.
>> (laughs)
♪♪♪
>> THIS WEEK, YOU HAD
YOUR VERY FIRST PHOTO SHOOT.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU
I AM PROBABLY
THE LEAST SATISFIED
THAT I'VE EVER BEEN
FOR A PHOTO SHOOT.
AS CONTROVERSIAL AS IT WAS,
THE MAJORITY OF YOU
JUST STOOD THERE IN YOUR PHOTO.
AS A MODEL,
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU
TO BE INSPIRING,
TO ENTERTAIN AS WELL.
13 GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
AND I ONLY HAVE 12 PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL
IS A PHOTO THAT IS NOT BORING.
JASLENE.
I'M SCARED OF THIS PHOTO,
'CAUSE I FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE GOING TO KILL ME.
BUT THAT IS THE EMOTION
THAT YOU WANNA PORTRAY
AS A MODEL, AND YOU DID IT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THE NEXT NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL...
BRITTANY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
FELICIA.
DIANA.
SAMANTHA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
I'M GONNA START CRYING.
>> CASSANDRA.
>> RENEE.
WHAT'S GOING ON IN YOUR HEAD
RIGHT NOW?
>> I JUST DIDN'T WANNA GO HOME
'CAUSE I KNOW I CAN GIVE IT
MORE THAN THAT.
(sniffles)
>> I THINK YOU CAN, TOO.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
SARAH.
YOU'RE THE GIRL THAT SAYS
SHE HAS ALL THE EXPERIENCE.
>> I KNOW.
I-I DISAPPOINTED MYSELF,
SO I HAVE SO MUCH MORE TO DO.
>> DIONNE.
>> (laughs)
>> CONGRATULATIONS, DIONNE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WHITNEY.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL IS...
NATASHA.
>> OH, MY GOD!
OH, MY GOD!
>> (chuckles)
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH!
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL KATHLEEN AND JAEL
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I HAVE ONE PHOTO IN MY HANDS,
AND THE GIRL IN THIS PHOTO
WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
SO WHO GOES HOME?
THE GIRL WITH THAT BRIGHT SPIRIT
AND HAIR TO MATCH
THAT JUST LOST THE MAP,
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT DIRECTION--
NORTH, SOUTH, EAST, WEST--
JUST DOESN'T HAVE A CLUE?
OR THE GIRL WITH
THE FUNKY, QUIRKY PERSONAL STYLE
AND THE GREAT PERSONALITY
THAT IS AFRAID TO SUCCEED
BECAUSE SHE WANTS TO BE LIKED?
♪♪♪
>> JAEL, YOU WON THE CHALLENGE.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> (whispers) OKAY.
>> AND YOU WON THAT CHALLENGE
BECAUSE YOU DID WELL,
AND THAT'S OKAY.
YOU CAN STILL BE LIKED
AND BE SUCCESSFUL.
OKAY?
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ALL RIGHT, MISS KATHLEEN,
YOU GIVE ME A HUG.
>> THANK YOU, TYRA.
BYE, GUYS.
>> OH, GIRL.
>> KATHLEEN, WE LOVE YOU.
(laughs)
♪♪♪
>> (crying)
I FEEL SAD RIGHT NOW.
I FEEL LIKE I DIDN'T
GET A CHANCE TO COMPETE.
YOU KNOW, TYRA BANKS SEES
THAT I HAVE POTENTIAL.
YOU KNOW, SHE CHOSE ME
TO BE IN THIS HOUSE.
THAT MEANS A LOT TO ME.
I'M GONNA GO HOME AND TRY
TO STILL PURSUE MODELING.
LIKE THIS IS WHAT I WANT TO DO
SO BAD.
I'M NOT GONNA GO HOME
AND SIT ON MY COUCH
LIKE A BIG COUCH POTATO.
NO.
I'M GONNA GO HOME
AND I'M GONNA WORK HARD.
♪♪♪
>> COMING UP
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
THE GIRLS ARE BACK
IN HIGH SCHOOL
FOR A PHOTO SHOOT...
>> THAT'S A CUTE POSE
RIGHT THERE.
>> AND A FASHION SHOW
WHERE SARAH INSPIRES
SCHOOL SPIRIT, WHILE JASLENE
FAILS TO MAKE THE GRADE.
>> JASLENE,
YOU MADE THE MOST MISTAKES.
>> I SWEAR,
I'M LIKE A TIME BOMB, MOM,
LIKE, I'M GONNA BLOW UP.